S
HADRG AUEOR FHE TKS BOO
ATBLPUICNIO SDAIS IT'OT N
NBSTEIHEKEC TLI REASTUT B ITS I
ACKINTEBEATHE T NT.ALURIS
REINTENEDST IAN HUME.AT NUR
H A'SROORROT PILBOERHI WCHS I
YWH I THINKRSEA RDEOU W FLDDIN
IT
IOR METIERNTESN TNGHA A MEOR
TYLCA SINBE.CK
WokBoTVONLIL C TNUTIE BONGRI
TW NEWGR PROSAMND AUB PGSHLIIN
NE
A CUANATOLS W O ACHLLFUR O
PPASTSGRROAMMENY ATI
Bo
RGTVok.O.
AOO GDONERFTNORY E,VEDYND A
E
TOMLCE AOSE HOUIV DEDID
CONGO T YOURO FMAH ABR
AM
OLLINCK BNOOP SHO INCA CHI.GO
E NMYAM I BJO SRNONPTKAAS AND I
BWILLEHE TIN ADMIVTRISAT FEOR
TH
ISGR PRO.AM
TH WOO BKTENN O TOAL T AKUTBO
TO IYS "NNCLIOLRIN I P BTEVA"Y
WNAROLDNDTEHI A YOUEA LRNOR ME
B
HATOU TK BTOO INT JUS A
NTMOME.
NK TIHIIT WHT THA I AMEA RDY TO
TURNOU YR OVEO T Y HROUTOSOR F
DATOY,AN D WLIEGNBEIERRO FM
RAHACO LMINK BLNOOHO SP.
DA.
>> TCOELME AO HIVSEOU DEDID.
I AAHAMLNIN LCO, IH. WIS
M AIE DANL WGNBEIERND ARE WE'I
SHOPN ICA CHIND,GO AUR O BOO
TDCOAASOTU SDIDEMB EED IDNUR O
OP.
YIS WHE WOUERER HEIT WH USS A
HYOUEEEAV B INNHE T P BTASUT
R NOOTEX BKE WOP HE TOAV H
E
YO T DUOT.HA
RS COFOU A WEEERRE H FEOROU YR
STLATEK BOOHI WIL WALL TK
ABTN I A MENOMT,LI " IOLNCNN
E"IVPRATFND A IOU YE WCHIN
H
WISEIL WLE HAVOO B SKSNEIGD
FO
R YOUN IHE TK BOOLA PT JUS
HIKELI T
O LROGNS I OT. I
CTHATROEAM FARM CANL SURDBG
NDSAR AEA YRS A,GOND A RONS IE
GOOGIN TE BNI SIGHONG T FSEORS U
N
DOR F YOUHE W YN OOUERRD A
BO
M FOKRO US.
LERO ISNTCEDUON R.IR FST
INHUNTONGT L,RAIBRYREN SIOTHE T
FE
OW O THENI TRIORTY F IUMN
WA, GTINONC.D.
HE
S H
GH TASAU ATTCL UA,OR COD
EGCOLLE,TW WHITHNIVE
I,
ATHE TNC PRIONETOL THE
ICOL
NASEMI.RY
EC'SHE L ARETUD W TTHETEHI
BUSHOE,NTNEE IEDVIEREW FORTH "E
NPBSR,SHEWOU L A"NDDTUECRE ON
NNCLIOL ARU TLYR OLLVE THE
D.RL
FMESO OREIS H POUVISOO B
KS
UDINCL AMECANESLY USS A,
N,NCLIOL AAPIO BGRIN,HY L
S
TEGREAEC SSTPEH,HE TON SECD
RAAUINGUER LL,IB J ATYND
TE
AFOR, RIAACLMEF RORN I THE
GCOSENDPEL.
ANRSUM NBEHEF  OOT.RS
ATSHI LOOTES B Y AKSROUCE SNES I
"LNLNCO ITERI PVAT W:HAIS H
ST PSONALE RLEF TIOCTNSLEL
UT AUSBOREUR O GESATT
PRENT.
R'SIT ADOANMOU HSEK, BOO 3
PA
ULSGE FLY IATUSLLTREDND AS I
$2
W, ID SAIOU YE'RN I ASE HOU
DID.DE
NES,YE OF O SHOE HWSERT A
3-ROU 8AR-OUANT AIQANRI
BOPSH, WUTERE A COMRTAB ALES
O
U C SANEEN I 2 THEt1s
YNTCEUR ENVEHO THUGE W ARE
ENTH19-CRIRYTU O
TEEND.
WANDEEVEE' BAD BNROGSTCAIN
THHO AEUTRVINT IEROWS,EW N
EDCALLSE H AOUIV DEDID,IN S
CE
,2004YEA RLLNS I BREPIDYAN BRI
SLAMBOR WK-SN O CN.PA
TIME WE HOP Y'LOULE BE HER
HEAT TRO BCAADSTOTU SDIED EMBDDE
INUR OHO SP, ANDE W WCOELMELL A
IEROU VORSWE TP DRONT IOUR O
SH
E HOPERN IHI CGOCAY B
WE ANK TREHA-SLFU CORNPA F
FO OINOWGGR PURRO FMIAMNGOR
RS YNYEA A,ND WE WCOELME
VANSP'S TWEIERS FOLWOT BHC-
U
E LRIVTR SMIEANGAD BRO ASTCA,
EHOUSEDIV DIDCH W,HIN OIGHT
NO
E TW,AK AAK BREIT W HHTOISRY
ISN ERYVEDA FRIY.
WEOHANK OUR PINLIUBSH
GPA
NERTRSAN RM HOU ASENDHE TIR
IBEENENTRNSUMNLTA IUT PNGTIV HE
TOHIERTH T O DSAYF REAELSE
HIT,EN T ISSHE TSEEL REAAT DEV
E
TFORS NOO BK ANDE WE HOP
WYOUOLLIL FLLWLO A OUROO BK
SI
EINGNG WNTVESAJHIT M
OR
ORAUTH T ISNHELD FIE OSF
N,NCLIOLIVHE T CARIL W,ND A THE
.
SI PS.RE
NTDES.
REYOU'INAT WCHGHI TS ON CPAN,
YOUL WILEA H RRONND ASE THEIL W
N OS AL WELO SOU Y CAN GO
TH W AENDAVLIL HESOP CIE
ITEDGN W THEOOKPHATELA T ITI
SH. YEDOU
SO YOP HEL WOUILIG SNP U AT
OUTEEB WSIOUO S Y CANEI RECVE
OTINOCEUTF FEUR ENTVES.
S TN,HI TOO BKOE, ME I'V BN
N
HE TESUS BIN OSF9 4 YRSEAOW N,
Y ADSOUAY SHI TSS I ANG THE
I
STNE BKSOOSHA TT'N BEE
HEBLPUIS L ODNCOINLNHI WCH
PE
NAPRHSEDOT TAL07, 100
ESTITL
ECABEUSNK T IHIOU YE HAV
ITITNSIVO IYNTLNIN LCO
BRINGRE GATIG INSHI,HT TS ISHA
REEF ALY RENCEOOKS AL WEL
OF L'SCOINLNAGER VBI BEUTT' IS A
LO ATIM H POGCHSYOL,ALICLY
NAOTEMIOSYLL AIT P AOLALIC
TEATNOCHCR A,S ANISTH EIC AS A
O
BRFWEULOKOO TD. REA
ASI W RDIEANGOME OFLNIN LCO
O
NDSRD A TS I AENAKCKBA, IE HAV
TEWRITLO SNO .
ITER PSOWECLFU BSEAU'R YOUE
GADREINLNIN LCON TAW R, THE
OWEPORS TFHIAGER VBI IESRU TLY
RDTREXAOARINY.
OT'SIT NUS JTOW THRUSAYAW M
.
IT'SLSO PLEROWFUSEEC BAUS A I
VEHAAY MNTBE IATIMED OFON
NGACTIS A ARE GEKRU CHO TSO
WESTHEOMDSOR CIN GEIVTE CGONXT
TOCO LIN'S WDSLA EXP
ING
WITHTO HISCARILHTNS IIG
ASIOUNGSIUR CIOO ITYNTOM SER
OF
HE TYS M IRITEES TNSEHE
FRNTMESNOT N TESOLL A THE
WILWHE ITIRING ANNE MANHAR T
T
DWOUL MAV HEEADCO LINLNRO P.UD
SO'M I G TNGOIOIR FSTRT STAIT WH
OTHEATANRGIZN OHI TS BOO
TH NOV CERSERUMOUTSSP AECF O
LIN, A VERCK QYUI ILYL WIL
EASTJU RT TDHAHE TPT CHAAVSER HE
IONE,NG G'MOI TOAL CLM THERA FG
SNOTESEEC BAU FHE TIRTSGMRAEN
AN
S.NOD TE
I' CLIALNGHE TMG FRAOT NES
TOY.
OF NGAIARALS FAL.CNC ANDDO TENNS
ONAYUE TSDHE WNE' HS COVINGN I
TH LIN LK,ICYRALCO LIN,LN A
LMBHULE,COINLN ARY FIE,
EDFEDEAT RCAUBEPLINC PN,RIALIP
DANRA OUTNCD GELIN.OL
ETHNI U LTY,COINLNHE T
KINTKEUC T AANNDHE TICOLHEOGAL
LI
OLNCN.
'STHATSHA WT'OV CEDNHE T
SE
CTENS,PTHAER ANDHE TNN A
AP
IXND.
YRON,OU DEDSEISCTSE THEAM CE
ENFFDIERBE MTAYIF1 1 D
REFT
SNOTEN ISE THEEN TERHA CPTS.
G'LWEL TOOHE TEN APPATXDI LER
ECON BHESEAU TRERE A 111
MEFRAGRAS,NT FES NGOT YHA TTOU
FO
D.UN
ASATWH W OOU YRINRRVEID
ATIDNSERNIOHE W CNGOSHOIN T
RASEPAPT CTEHAG FERRA IOT NESN
THOO BK?
IR>> FED SSTPEHOS I CEOS THE
SPEASCTFUT B I TYHEOP P OUTT A
ANYOU
AYYW?
OIR FSTF, ALLHA T YNK SOUO
MUEIOR F BNG A PTARF OOU YR
PR
ORAOGMGAENC A.IN
'SIT A VYEREA RLIG DELHTN I
PR
E.ILIVEG
THIS
TH
A IISSONGINDITONG SRF
.ME
FENWH INCSTIR EEDNTOUERIN L
O
AWAS TTHETI HUNTONGN LRAIBRY
EXNTBI I3- 199
.94
ASI WINEA TCHTO HGISRY ATCL UA
AN
A HDAD CICHOEF OHO AUTNGRI A
ONAMIR MFYWN O.
SAD H A RDIEANG ANDOM CPEFMIU O
I
SOLNCN',OR WDSHEND A W INT
TMEOHE TDEC SONUG INAASALUR W
MVERYH SUCK BYT I BUT A
WANT TO WNO KWTHAAS W THE
DETEANCE ONTF TS?HI
EAI LHEEDRN T WREAS AOCUMTEN
WN BATRONI UY,RSVEITINCO'S
GYOUNTAEC SREE HRYAVIT T IDLET,
I
DOLNCNN'TYPEIT ENTS,IE
CA
HEEDLL TIT MED OIOATN TNHE
NEDIVIIL WL.
T IDVERALERO FMTH SOUNER
LIFOIA TWN BORORSNI UVEYIT
TOOL HD A SOOLIE PCEF O BELU
LIER PDAP MN IDS HYAN.
HIADO NDE I AATHE T TEIMT THA
WERTHEOEER S MANY,AN MY, MYAN
NOSTE ANDE I'VAM C TEO THE
SINCCOLUON TTHAOS MTEO PE
NO'TDN KE.THW OS
SOHEF O T ASEREIL FAMOMR,IA SE
ARHEN I T BHIGRIOAP OESF
BOLNCNUT I T WUGHOHTED NEEO T
SECO LIN HLNL,ALND AHE WN I
ACCONTDTELAN DIEOR WONINTHGT WHO
IS THEDI ERTOF O THELNIN LCO
TPEPARSRETHA AN I SIEINPRGF
LE
AI SDE WVEEL BIERE THE11'S 1
HE TSEOT NEST THAAV H
ESU
.IVRVED
I'UR SINCOROLN W HTESDRUNED
M TOFHERE A 111AV HEUR SVEVID.
I ATEANDENSE TOUT POR BEF
E
LEPEOPHE TTERI PVACO LINLN
THIBEND PHELIUBCCO LINLN.
O SHO TSEEC ASP,TS THE
OUSE,AG I HHA TT YOWOUIR FST
REBEFO T D,IDRAHE F JENGMTSTUSOR
POUT OT A YOU AIV GE YOU
AOSTHE OECSPTSOLLIF NC
T>> INKHIHE TGM FRAOPTSEN P
E
AOUTE. M
IANID WOT T WTERI A 700AG PE
OOKBO S IAD ME AIOEC DIS TNO
FOSN O TENERHA CPTH WSIT
MEFRAGS.NT
LSI AE HOAV HADHE TVI PRIGELE
HIMECO TLL RSEAYPR SUREEDIS M OF
NA TINATGHE AOKIOUDBOAL U,SU
N
HE MLYICAME LLOBEB SAOMYOD
HAKELI TS GTETOO T DT, TO LET
MEO IT.
HEIN TBOUD AIOOKY THEAI S ADRE
TH FOR METSGMRAEN WOU YLDOU
LIO TEA RD?
IHENEA RDIV FE ME.OR
N I AEN SSE IHO C 1SE7,UT B
TH
ME'ERSORYAN M IEOULD HAVE
FO
SECUD ONT WHA IAN W TT HOE
TTHESEIM A YOUGE SUGNEDST I
IYOURCTRONTDUONIO T TAK TE
HE
FTIMEORHE T RDEEARO TEN SSE THE
EXCONTT, THETYLE THE
DI SENERTLETYSF OCO LIN,LN
VE
IC LRYYRLE SALTY AGA NIARA
VLLFAS,IFYER D KREFENTFDIN O
ST S IFNFEOM O THEENRA FGM
TN
D NESOT.
>>SHIOO BKS I ONEF THE
RE TSON ITNKHI I ISO S
TRTPOANHAS I TT ITGSEL BON ON
EVYCO LINKS BLNOO
LFHE.
RIGH NEX T TTOHE CIVLEOLCTE
WO
SRK BYOY RSL BASEC,ER BSEAU
WI11 1RA F AENGMTSNDRE AOT N
L I TREHE.
ANOORHE BT TKHAEX NT TOS I
RE
TELLCOECDS WDORF O ARA BND
N.NCLIOL
ETHOSHREEIT TSLEELONG
TOSERTH AALAS BIC ALY
RE BNCREEESKOO BES GDOO
REODPES RI.
WHNK TEYHI HHE TY BADNEEO S
OKEROVLO?ED
IDLLWI DOS MT OM THEEES RID
TH
Y TATHE NAV HEOTEE BND USE
MU
CH BOREFE?
>> TREHE'SRO C H,SSEUGESOL VUM
LNIN LCODS W'SOR,HE TST FIRY BOF
A
T AYND BNHEYRAS VSAN I THE
NAV HEUIEREV QEETE SNHE T
ERGETOTHNT UIL QTEUITLEC REN
YTH
LD WEYOU AEN BTNDLL AINDS OF
DIENERT LESRAIBRI T,HECO LINLN
PPEPARSJEROCT INPR SLDGFINIEO T
THOURE PVIS YRSEAS AIT DIGEIZ
.THEM
TH OWN10 1 OF T. 1HE11
FOYATUNELOR F M IE KW T
HE
LEGENTNNMA IS,AL DLA,EX TAS
W
DOWNEFNE O O THERE G TESATTCKRA
CIPRINHEL,PA TENRA FGM
OTF
ERSLAV H AY,NDE AND HIS
CH ATEACREOT L B USEHA TT
FR
IMEAGNT TNHEOO BK.
NE>> OF O TNG THI -S-HA T
S'
ERWONDBOLFU AS TUTHIOO BK -- IS
YTHATOU SWHOHE TM, THENE O IS
THERHA CPTS, RIGER HE IN
LI
NGVIOL C.OR
HEDAN TLL RYEAOM BYECE MEORHA TN
SJUST WWIHONGHETHA T VEBIERAG
WAHAND A WHET TYDOO LKE
I.
YBUT AOUREWI SHOM TNGHE AS
FAARTIS.CT
VATTH'SMPYER I FTAORNTPL POREO
O
BLE B AE TOEE SSE THE
RIMATESSAL AACRT AIF.TS
IDWHO D YOUET GOU YR PERLIUBSH
PTOOPOU FRCOR-LOTRLL IUS
S
HEIN TEID MDLF OS THIOO BK?
SY MUTHOUT OIR, FSTHO SUT OUT
GOESO MYHE PLMENONARDI ETO
CANLIcK MNAEN.
SHATDV AOC T FEDORSHIH WIT
RA
OUOMND HS,SE A'R YOU
E
ESSUGGNGTIS THI I NSOT
IVPEEXNS P TEOHINTRI TSNG IN
ALOCOR, SNDOHT RIGN I THE
ERNTF OHE TOO B 1K6ES PAGN I
CO A AR,ND HSEO ALSUG SSTGE,
YOEEAN C S THEIN KDF O RLEA
NTAGFRME D T,HENTFEIFRE
COONSAERTI
A'REYELL ONREIF DFEINNT K
.AP PER
YOEAAN C REEYLL SLNIN LCO'S
WRHAND
INITG.
HOSO S T OUTUTOINAI CTL.
SH PER AADSUEDND RTOU AOUABTSND
NK TTOHIS I ATI DIS PTINCVE
TR
HEOF TK. BOO
GE' WREONGOI T SHO SW OEOMF
THOUS A Y SAKPE.
N'SIT ASIMP IOS FLIBITY AORLL OF
OUWE W BLDEER H FEOROU H BK,RS
HWHICURRE A M FREDEDORLYRA FNK
12RSOU OFUE QIONSUTLL WE'
OYTR TOL HDT IN DOWO SHE T
VISN DEROE'T FLALP,SL AEE
Y.FUPELL
YOONEN MTICO LEDIN'SLN
HAGITWRINOWND A H LHE TCOINLN
PPEPARSJEROCTAS WEL HULPFIT WH
HLLKEYOUPEL YN IND UDISTERAN
O
CO LWINAN'SLN HNGRIDWTI
CHD ORIM TE.
I IELYSFLLN AY M YRS HAV
E
SEEN INAN H LINDLG
COINLN
INWRITE HGSAVNT IDE CIEIFDEOM
FO
TA IRNSE FNTIVREIF DFE PHA
TH HESE UDT THA IK LOO. FOR
II'VEIENTDEIFD TT.HA
ET SUOMESIMSE UNE O DOT O TRWO
O
F OTSRGEORTSO T PUTOT DS
TTEAFRTHA. A
WHL C IAL A RLEOLREROA CST HE
TESDON' HRO CSSS. KISEY
AOSTHEOSSO T RHEHTIGBO AVE
THRDWO.
TMANYESIM IND FOUIN DURISG H
IDPRESECYEN H HKEARNSAC BKO T
EHISLIARER SNATUNSRE IHE T
50s ',s40ND AN EVE T
HE'3
.0s
IDATWH DHE TL YOUBO AUT
LI
SOLNCN' HTIDWANRINGNA A
G?
IEL WL, ASK HERT THA
ONESQUTISEEC BAU BHE S'DNEE
INAMEXIN IGT FOREA Y A,RSNDER H
ATSEOBRVHIN,IO W A ICHS GERENAL
ATSEOBRVOUN,IO YS IY VER
FUHELPE ML,ORFIPE SCI IF SHE
FE TVE OR AEIMS HEGE ADIS H
HAGITWRINFTEN BAMECEERMA SLL
N
D MEOREDOU RND,HA TTE H HAD
LESDNE AONVE ERY IENS THI
RAGENEOUONTI WE HLDAVEDEA LRN
IPANNMSH T B,YHRNHE THEGHOU TPE
SYEAREGT I BANO T CNGE ANDHE S
O
ATDUL W ICHTNG CHAHRED TGHOU
THARYES.
'L>> I T SLAYSHIHO T WH,UGNHE HE
SI HEDIS FLULAM NEAH ABRAM
N,NCLIOL HHI WCHE HADO TO DOR F
EV OFFIAL DT,UMOCENTH WHE
R
IBAS LALSSRE P,DESINT I
HEKIN TSAP PERCTRO PJEE CAM UP
OMTHWI S LHIETNGEIK INK THI'V IE
COMEP U WHIT05, 300F OM THEUT O
HEOF T,0 100+ TTRE A IN HIS
HA HHA TT HEAD T SONIGL, FUL
MIOMRYTA CNSSSMIIOE H SNEIGD
LAT MEOSF T TE.IM
SOSTIMEMEONTA SNTDIG SNEARO S H
H
HEAD NOM. ROO
TOSTANER LNAT IAD ME STLLMA AND
NLHE EGEDNDWE SHOFFD OIS H
URGNSIAT A TEOAN MHA T HTEAS
SEFFGIN OAY MBEO T BE KLEILD.
YO MLS AOEDTIENONN IR YOU HOW
ETHESENRA FGMTSAN MYIM TELO FOLW
K BAOOHA TT HEAD HUS J RTD OR
LYCERENT
EA RD.
SO AHE TRENE CREON FIOCTNSMRO
OOETH BKSE HD. REA
GIS UN ADE IABO A TUTT,HA
.EAPLSE
OVIEWCO LFINLN IS HE DN'IDT
Y MADANKS BOO T,THAE HTL MOSYE
ADSP NEW
ERAPS.
IWHATND FOUNT INGESERTIN I THE
ONESQUTIUG B IROHTO T THEK TAS
ISEMYLF DS,ID TSEHEOT NESAK ME
THR WAY IONTIS HIS FIN
DHE
SHPOLILI PEDUB SCS?ECPEHE
FTSTMO OY TENHE D. NIDOT
E FT,OR,MPXALE HEEA RDSS THI
VE SOKLAAI ORYRDDNEF OOD G A,
O
BYYTRE PSBINYER MTEISR
FR
KEREDICOS RSN I 17.85
A IISSNER INTTIESNGTO SRY
ECABEUSAMIL WLIONER HNDAD H
URENCOIMEDAG H SO TBESCUBRIO T
VAS AI-SLERAVYAPEW NSPSER,
H
CO LENINLND SAIO T HER, CAN
ABUTANOLS WOT T SBESCUBRI TO A
MORICHSP NNDEWERAPR OHE T
STARCHLERI CONOU.ER
OUYWH W YLDOUHAO D TT?
D SHEAIE W NDH BOTID S OESF
TH
E.TAE BL
ON THI TNG IT'HASNTORMPTA FOR
TOPPELEOAYOD TER UNDAND,E
BNTWAEDIDHOT SFES O THELE TAB.
SOEAE R TDSHIRO PYAVSLER BKOO
RIRE FDES, RCKOSSB PRE
ERY
STMINIERM FROTS HUN
LLVIE,
AMALAB A AA,NDHOUG HEID D
'
EAGRE WHITT ANDLD WOUIN F
L
ROFFEOT A NE INAN MYAY W
S
LECHAL IINNGG W HFETANO T TRY T
UN WTARSNDETHA H WASGAY SIN
HEDAN T HE WLDOUPO RES.ND
THAS HIS -- AHHOLTUGT I
,DNDI'TT I WASEV NERUO Q IDTEN A
SPHI ICH TNKT IAS WAR P OTF
HINK THI AGIN HUTBO AM I
TINGOGAC AOTTKLAVE?RY
T T>>HASRI BNGO THE T QNSTUEIO
WE TRTTAEDOAL TKUT ABO
ADALREY,HE TGE USA OFSE THE
FRNTMES.
EW,NO HRO WTEN IER ORDSP TO
A
'STHATEE BN BUGHT UP AND I
AGH WEIT TT.HA
THT W'SHA WE H WASTING F,OR
N
TA CDERHELYIN TNDERNINGE H
ODOESY MNAN OFIS HOR WDS FOR
ISPHEMASHI I, T INKSMP E
SIS
SFORG,AKPEINOT NUS JT TNKHI.
ANOUF O CSE,RS AOU Y SGEUGST
'SHERI W HNGTIISUG THONDSHT A
YISTUD THETHERID SEF OHE T
ISE.SU
HOEAR TLL RSEEAHEY T MNAI
REOSON TOL HDIS HUG THONDHT A
IVTO GEC SEPESHEVE ENHHO TUG
PEEES SLLFICICAN' DYIDAY ATLWH
A
I IKETONTHE TM?
>>NK THI YES YOURE A.IG RHT
HEHIID T TSOE HON H TISUGHOHT
U
S HTE'LS AOOR ST O DEBINATG
THWIINLFIM HSE.
SISTH IT PARF O WTHA IHI T INKS
IMP ITAORNTNSTND UER
DIG
AHIM, INDOU W TLDNKHINY A
LE
ERAD IAN WOOO LK FOROD T.
THEL IENTLCTLEUASIUR CIO.TY
N' WIAST JTUSADE H HEDRR AIVT
THEUSON CCLHANIO T ITST'HEAY W
HE AIVRRES TTCL CHEON
IO.
E'THEROG AS LALICINCOER,LN V
Y
CALOGICO LLIN.LN
MEMESOTIS I AOSLMTAN CGI IMA
NE
HIMS AAW L WRYEKIALNGP U AND
DO
C AWNOMRTOUROIN KD OF
ECPROS AINUTGE CASGA ASTIN
SL
AERAVYESOCDVAT
T SDOSSHI I W AAY OFIM H
OINRKGUT ICTELNTLELLUAY WTHA
E
SHI TNKUT ABO ANSSUE
.
TISOMEHESME T AOT NES AREADHEF O
EATWH H SIL WL.AY
INORERTH WE',DS HS A LTLITE
MOCU CIR MPEMSCTAYE B IN A
PUEC SICPE Q NH,OTTEUIDY REA
TO SAYET SOM INGHINIS H
LATIAN-SRYVE.
AT WCHHE TEL DEVMEOPNT OFHI TS
ENVE SYLAUG TRYHO BHTUT YOU
EENCA SHE TOU FNATNDIOF THA
T
INHE TSE NESOT- -I- ANTYAVSLER
THT.GH
>> TAN WT A AOSKOMUTBO S OEF
THNAOM CMOTIESHATHE T
YHA
.VE
>>ES.
E>> HSEL DVE TNT IOHEIS HLRITOCA
NOAN MYIM T,ESND AER OTH
S,
TMANYEESIM HEG B WSINHIT A
CH ANGLEENDNN ISH WITOM S
E
TCALLCTO AN.IO
>>
ES Y.
HERE A TER ORETH CLIMOOMNAESTI
DEBESIS,OU Y CANAL T AKUTBO
AESTHE, INDSS, THIND AOS MT OF
PESHI S AHEECSEL WL?
OU>> Y DAV HENEERETMI
ODR
DEDRISCBET IEL WL,HA TTS HE'
RNEVEKI TALUT ANGBOHI TSUS JT TO
NVEHA AEL INTLCTLEUA
COONSAERTI
T AS YOU S,GEUGSTND A I TRY TO
OINPOTFT,UT OHEEN T A'SREAL CL
CTTO ATNIO A THE ENDF I YOU
DO T GTETHAO TT C ALEALDION
YTIUNLE HOUAVEN TAK THEIM TE TO
TADEUNRSNDSSHE T I.UE
DANO S LCOINLNS I WTIANNGO T
AL WHITHA TT.
XARFO E HLEMP,ERSE' V CYEDCEONRN
WH HEOI JNS THEUB REP
CALN
PART THA HTEOE D T'TSNNKHI THE
NCHEADRE OEFHE T PTYAR AREUI Q
E
EAWARF OOW HUC M THHEARTY IS
BE
GINEDHA CRGH WITIS SEXM HERE
TH IHI TSS OYNL AUA SEXARL PTY
EDAN WAV HEO TEA DLIT WHHI TS
ISUTESU BT AHE TND E OFHE TOT NE
N
RHE TCAUBEPLITY PNARHA TT I
UDINCL W BEUT ATHARE WEHE TREO T
DOUTBOHI TS?
W AATREEFOHE TRERE AUTBO TO
DO
?
GER WEONGOI THO SWHA TT AND
TALKBO AUTT THA A LTLE BIT
MOES A W GO.LO ANG
OF CRSE WE KWNO HOWHU STOU MTH
I
OLNCNAS W,S AIS H LAWERAR PTN
H
DIRAR LGEAR PERTNIL BLY
HENOI P OEDNTUT AND
BESCDERI HDIMNG BEIHU STTH MOU.
GIS U AN E OMPXALEFOW H HIS
IN
EERNE F RNGLISLLEAYHO SWFF O
NE O OFHE TSEG FRAOT NESHA TT
O
HAV HER
A HANTOISRIHA WT YOUEL BVEIE
TH OHO SWS TFHEAN M?
ST F>>IRF OLL A J,TUSHE TLE WHO
TIQUESONEEF O F
NGLIS.
HII TT TNKHAE W NDEEO T
KENT MKYUC, AINOVG ASNG YOUOY B
TONTHOUERNAND IIAW G,REP UN I
H
WATE WLDOUAL C TLHEDEC SON
GR
AKT EAAW
INENG.
HISTSAR PENTT A BDEEND
TIAT
CHCHURT TESHAER WERE EXTLYME
NAOTEMIO
M FDROY V AEROU Y ANGGE
LIEANOL RGAEDCT AHISTIN TS
KIF O EALTIMOONNM,IS I
RE
BGILIONUTTI EMOMALONIS
GE
LLRAY.
ASHE WER VYAR W OY KINDF O
FE
,INELGSE WAN W TTOE B A
ALTIRAONN.ER PSO
ASHE W T AUGHTL P
SOER.
OUI F INDTUI QTE RBLAREMKAN WEHE
TERE RSUNOR F THEE,EN SAT
NATEE RREMEMBEAS WEDLE ECT
TE SBYTA LTUISEGLAES,RE H IS
DEFEED ININ MAK
5G5.
EAHE LDS ONHE TIR FST00 7 T0
GBI IUESSS I THEAN KBRS-SANEKAAS
C
TH WT,HE SLARY WLDOUE B
PE
DITRMTEOO T GT WESNT I TOHE
IEITRROR E ASNDHONVE THUGIS HTE
NCHEADRE WETIANNG TO SYTA INHE T
RAINE H F CLYALESCLONUDE H
WNNCAOT.IN
ITDAN W SRAHDWST TOHA A DEMRAT
TH BIM TE HUTIS ANTNEBRKAAS
LLWIIN W.
NNCLIOLS VYNIAG MNANUSMO I
ICPUBL ARDERFTWA
Y, O'SKA'M I ALLIG RHT
HIEREVYT T INGNSHIAR REM
BLE
NO T HTEE AKSALUTBOHE TT FAC
THAT HISIF L IE NSHIOTNGUT B A
FA
NURILE, BHIOTNG A FLAT
URILE.
OUHE WER NLDEV SAV HEHADAI T ITN
ICPUBL
OU W NLDEREVE HAVXP E
SSD
ETHOS OIN KDF DATP-EESE
ELINND,GS ASHA TT' WTHAAK MES
H
ES NEOTO SOR F ATHREE HER NEV
EDPEEXCTOS U TEA RDM. THE
EWE'ROT GNG TO SEEM THET A
THCO LEINKS BLNOOPHON  I
21.
WHE'STIRINGOR F H,SEIMLFUT BE H
X
SESPRSE TSHIYEA RLLRT HEALTFE
INFEEL L MG,YSEIF I ALU FAI,RE A
FFLAT.LUAIRE
BOT THAUS J STUCTRKE. M
UT>> BNET Y I TTHAREAI FLU IN
RAPCHTEOU FR Y HOUEAVHE T
EILFAUROT N
E.
EMAYBANE W C SEE IT.
PO SKEF OHA TTN I6 185UT BE H
N
ODSN AIT POSTEE IVNO
.
E>> HS DOE.
IMPO ORT T ATHANDLNIN LCO'S THE
CH TTEACR,ETHA HAD H TTHA
EILFAURUT HES IOR MESI POSYBL
HSOE CAN GO ONSP EYIAECLLIN SCE
O
A AUSNRE OPP CIVSSEERRAHACT
ASENO KW.
T F IEDHEER EXP ANCIEE
O
ENSTUD A WTSHOTURE SINDYG I
N11
DE GthRA AND ANRIMECA
HIY.OR
L WIIL AFT OENOW LGONO D YOU
KTHINT IK TOOIN L TLNCOORI WTE
NOESTHE S?TE
EYIL WL S TAYWOUT MINHR,ES TEE
MIS, FR M.UTINES
IDAIOW HBO AUT ANOU H ORRWO T
OR
EEHR?
HII TT WNKHANEAP HPED OENFTAS W
NNCLIOLRIS I WNGTIHI TIG RHT
HT IDPEAPNEND AE H PSEAUSND AAS
OS AHELMS STAY TO HIMLF,, WOW
H
ISEL ITS PET.
ITHISTT PSRETINEY GA.VE
HEDAN T HNENS TURT I AUND AS
YOSTUG SGE --F- SEL -TYPI- I
HA
NVEO,'M I NOTEA JUSF
STOUNHE DLLASGL AHE SUCSSCE
HE HAS ADIECHVEE HS ENDN O A
VE
RYOS PIVITEOT NE,T THA HE
WA
HASNT WT HEAL C TLSHE
DESPRSEF M SPE TESCIOE BP
UFTLIED
HA'SAT W G MTYLOA IS.
HE
TOE DSNURT IRO AD.UN
IHI T MNKYAN TESIMLNIN LCO
LYOBPRABDAU PSERIN I WHENGTI T
NO ASNDAI SD M OH,YESOO GDN
N
N TDHE IAK TESTN I AREIF DFENT
J Y>>OUTUS RDINEMDE MET THA
IWHENEE SLNIN LCO'S
ONESPRSI ANDE H NADBEUMRS
THIMOM SETES WDSORDSRI FEN
TO
WAVUIDEIS ISNSRODTE F
MHI
RE TM,HEER WERF FEAFUL OIM H
TAISNGKI HWN O LE,IFHY WN' DIDT
DHEO TT?HA
ECABEUSOSITELYANE H WODTE T
MAFE D AIF INCREE TNHEOR WLD
BE
EREFO HT LEFT. I
>>.ES
GAO S AINHA T STWSHO
TIPOSI TNEVESSROTHA BHT I OUT
EP DN,SSREIOCHEL MANYOL,HA T
T
OUHE CTI CLDONNENU OIT W HHIS
LI ANDOR W IKNOT N DOY AWA
TTHWI I BAUECSEF O HISEE DP
SIPRDEES T FONORE.IM
LAMI' G R YDOUDINEMDEFE M O
.THAT
ANHIRHE TT' TNGHAE NSIC
T
THISOO BK ISHA TTAC EH CHAER
HAHE TRE P MCEFA,NIEANG A
OLLINCGE INMAHA TTHO SWSIM H AT
TH OIM TEF THEOT NHATE H
EDLOOK
IK LE.
HASO TST'TH ANOARER P TTTHA
PELE CANNJOY AEBL TOEE S
OLLINC T ANTEIMF O FLUAIREND A
WH
L HATE LKEOODEIKT AT THA
.TIME
WBUT AERE SAKIN OGFIN L
S
ACCHARR.TE
TE WURIHA TT L,COINLN,UO QTE
EM
DIBOEDHE TDE IFAL OHE TF SEL
PLEAAN ESEXPDHE TCE CONNDPT A
IHOWLI ATPP TEDOLNIN LCO.
>>ERLEL HIP IE TY M HATO T MY
OWFELLRIIS HTOIE DANANLRAL WKE
HO
AND,OR HEUE ARGS
VEUARSSIT TLYHAHA WT ITEA MNT
IN9tHE T 1TU ChENORRY ST OF A
E-MLFADOUAN M YIG MHTAY S
,SE
MEBECAER VYFE DIFNNTRE I T
HE20
IN Th 2HE0tRYEN CTUE W
ATSOASCIH WEITOMEOAD ME IT
OMECON,ALICLY W
,E MHOADEA WH,LT
DVOWH ACEAND TMSEL
S.VE
TBUTTHA WAS NOTOW H IT WAS
ME 1 ITN9EN CRYTU.
SE CCTSTONRUNT MEDEAEO SOMNE
SOWH I ON A MALOROU J WEYRN,SEHO
O
LRAE LIK WASN I A MALOR
.LIUPFT
LIOLNTLM AOS BIK LENJAENMI
FR
WKLANIND KASIN OF TINAKG
PEAL IENTO ORYFSE HIM.LF
OG RHEEC TZENIDSTHA AOU YNG
MA
W HNEASIMOM SETEN GESIVO T
UMDBA H TORO ANGACTTKISTH OERO T
A
ASRCM.
ASHE WWA ARE OFHO TSEUA QTILIES
SE HINIMND,LF A HEDAN WTE TO
BMOVEE O TM,HEND A HEID D.
THHAS I WTT INS MEA TO BE SEL
COD.UCTRTE
LINOLS I ON AER P MNASOLALOR
ODNYSE IIS H LE,IFND A HE
GR ASND HEHA C AESNGNDHU TS I
MINTHKIMESAK HO STT AE.CTRAIV
LIST IINENGD NNEEO T R WDEATHA
OLLINCN.RO WTE
TREHE INIT WHIR YOU OWN MD.IN
THIN ODS WORY, B THEOO BK
WUSCAEOTREE' NBION CNU TALOE
GO
EVE ORINRYVETHG INER HE.
EEYTH'R AUC SHOW PERS A I
DIONTNEERAR ELIBO AUTCO LINLN
DAN THEEK GRE C TRUHOSTHA RON
ESOVPRIDO T AS PLULO A TNGHE
JO
ONEURYER UFNDNGANSTDI IT.
ARNIAGLS FAAL TOT NETHA HHIT THE
EWR
E.
ANOUS A Y, SAY IST'
SIRPSURILYNG L.ICYRAL
RE
F IADTORRS YOUF.EL
IT ILLEAYSHA TT.
BUOU YRI WTE HE WASLS AORA C
T
INHE TAI DETHA,LS TT HE
EDOVSCER THELSET DAI OF THE
FA
UCSLL S AHSHE WRE THE WERAT
M FMEROND A THEON T OGENAFHE TA
TTEWARTHAE CAMGHHR TOU.
Y DYOOUHI TNK HERO WT THA
DO
?WN
WHEID D H USE ALLHA T ITNHI TS
TTENO,IN REMSE HDIM?LF
WH
Y?
WASESNT IERDTE INER RIVNDS AHRE
E ORTFRIINNGEE ANGNDLL AF O
ORATTH S OTFTU SFFGHHR TOUTOU
SHIENT EIRIF LE.
LWAS W A ISAYTEERNTES IDN
CA
N,ATUSIOHA WT WAS CSEAUDN
ITHISBLRENCDIENO PHE
NOME.
IWHAT
RY I TO T SEEN IHEON C
E
OFER UNDNGANSTDI CHE TTEONXTOR F
RTHE IDEEAR,T TSHANG YOU
ANERAMICEL FTEW SOMTHA INF
R
NGTO ENDNDLA AOP EURNE I TMSER
OFLD CTOU NOTAT MCH THED KIN
OF CLTUULRAARIT LERYALUS MIC
AR
ICST.
WBUTTTHA IOU C OLD TERFFTHA
CO B NDOT OEEREDN I EOPURE
WA N BURATAL
UTEAY.
BANDOREFEEL YNEWSLOTO OR
,MISETEAST I WIA N FRAGALSAL
THHEAS W TRE GAT AIORATTCTN
AFORNSRIMECAINF O LLNCO'S
RAGENE
ONTI.
SAND G HOESOEHE T W,RETERIS
TH
AM DN.
LYSURE HOM CEHT MEIG BEINHI TNK
A
WEYB ILDOUSE US THIN I THE
FUGH WREEI A ATNDREEC LTU B,UT
US'SHE JTI CTAP BTEVADYT. I
AKATWH M IEST SOER INTTIESNG
SNAI I HHE WNEES COMAC B AKNDG
SH HESISXP EEIEERNCH WIT
HDORNN, HNDERONADEE BNHE TRE
I
RELMSFYENECTLERND A HONND
TKEMASMASHI ANG,HA T LTCOINLN
HAO CYACAPITOR F
NDRSDETAHEGIN TYEA BUTF O
AAGNIAR FLSAL.
OT'SAT N MHE TAN I KW.
DHER KN'IDTWNO THE MANSEEC BAU
RAISTH F SENGMTWSHOT THALNIN LCO
M
INAZGAD H THEITAP CAC FYOR
PRECTINGEAHE T BFYUT O
NIAAR FLSAL.
EE >> ST ILYRO BAD INMS TER OF
H
IATSHE CONSAAUTIF O TH.IS
>>ST' REINTEINSTG,OW NHE WIN
READOU THR IGHT AND GOT TO THE
EN YOUONEN MTI,EDHE T REIS,
E'THER AS C AMAOMTHT END E AS
EIF HEN WT ONFT AER IS.
OUT,BU Y INO KW, FT TEL ISWA A
POULRF DIEN. NG
CTUAYED ENDHE WRE T INKHI
T
SHAULHOD VE DEEN  D.
MAYB HE PUTHE T CMAOM AND
SA
,ID NO, I'M DO.
I  DTN' AONY .TTBEER
AUGHR]
>>NK T IHI AT' IS FSULABOU
TTLEERND A T INKHIOM CMAR O ,NO
I
MOLNCNE  HAYAV HENSEHAE D
METH TO E D.EN
SYOERNEULHODD REA DOHERNSN'
TIREACAU BONEC NSEOTNLY D
NOHE KNC WLIN,OLEOU Y'R
NIARNGOR MBOE AUT WLIILAM
NRNHEDO TNHA AUTBO L WCOINLNNHE
E
RDORNN TCTEASO  ISTH.
ANHE TTH OERNG THIE HSE US
HE,S I THEOR WD EF"INDITINE"
AN HE UDSE T WTHADOR I HNIS
EADRMHA TTE HD TOL L OERATF
GILSAINDOW TAR AN DEINNIFITE
SHE.OR
S. >>YE
BE MAY  A
CONQRU
R-NQCOUE-
DANCCOORENCND A THE N OBEUMRF
METISE HSE UD ?THEM
N W>>EDEE IT D,'TON ? WE
MU'YOVEEAD A CONCTION ,HERE
OTVEHA NHTHO TUGF OHA TT
COTION
WTHEDOR ND"IE"INEFIT ,YE, AH
AHYE,AH.
'L IL EN S YDOU MILY BLN  I
ETH RNMOG.IN
T' T>>HAR YSOU EX NT.BOOK
[LTEGHR]
>> AHYE, RIT.
IVHE G O OESNETHF EOS MTAM FSOU
TENOS, LOER, ANDV AEIC TO A
U
INDDG. WYLAER
NOW, ITE WAND TOHO SWEC BSEAU
CAWE N,E HERAMBR AAHLNIN LCO
BOOK OPSH .
AVWE HGI OERILNAIF ARTTSAC SHUC
AS TSHI NEOT WTTRIEN BYLNIN LCO
THEAN HFD O UTM,HI B FOR HIS
SE LNDAW P ATNARERNDS HE'
WRGINN I A  SECA.
STIC AEND JTIUSCEER V SSU
GA TANH DHET COS OF IT
.
ANDHE TSERE A SEOMEF  OTH
TH
GSIN WHAE   D.
SISTH IHA WT HISRIAN HDWNGTI
SO,HE TRERE AAN MYTSSP AEC TO
ATHE HICDVEEIV GES REHE, NOT
TO TEAK AAY PN I E,VAADNC
H
IS AREINN TEINSTG TUGHTND A
OFRSOUE, ON STHONE  Y.
ARDAN WDL HILAS W AYE LAWR AND
A
'TSN THE TRERD GOUAIN LLNCO
WH
HENEDEE NDEIM HO  TNDBE A
O HNTIM TFFOHM RICDONIL APR SE
14O SE HTAS WN' E.THER
LISN OLWA P AIAITOLICN AND
WYERND AAM LBDONND A H IAD A
NO TTHAD SAI TH,HA TT
OLLINCLD CNOUTR SHECHET TRU TTH
WH NECEARY.
SON MILASN' ATSEOBRVN,IO
HOS YST IINS THI NOTEY V,ER
RTIMPOUTT,AN BHA WT T YOUNKHI
MTHETEN COGT ATSUMRGENRE A
N
HI TSG LON TENO.
LL WEE, H BINEGS IN A
ABMARERK.  WLEAY
THEISOT NE AT DED BYAS BRLE TO
BE1850
WEEM REMHARBE TTIN LLNCO SVEERD
ON TERN I CO,RENGSS 4718
HENEET RURD HO.
HEAK TEN A VYERGTR SON
AANSTDINGASTSI PREAMNTDE JES
PO IN THEAR W WHIT MICEXO AND
I EKIN H GHTHOUT, AND MY
MAGRVEHA AITDEE WH M,HI TTHA
I
IT PSOLARALIC CASREE W EROV.
HSOENSET RUR TOOM BECE A
LA
ERWYLL-TE,IMVE TRAINLLG
8THE JTHLICUDIAITIR CCUN I
RACENTLI LIL ISNO.
SDORAS BLEAT DES THE
MEDOCU ANTSUL JY 5018 .
INI TH IT S PYBAROBL  A
LELITT TAT LERNHA . THAT
IIN FDHAT OLLINCN,HE RATR
AU TOUCISTE WORI A L TTUECREO
LASERIG R AW.
HEDIY D TE WRI THE LECTE?
IURJEONCT W HEEASINPE SNDG
195,18 S D0AYUT ON O THI
AUIRCT P TNDHEECTRAICF O CI
BE
AMICONGRAW LYE WAS T BOOME
CA IRKLEN A LAWIC OFFNDE A AS
LIECNOL BE A VYER
-KWELLWNNO WYLAAN,ER M LYYEAWRS
WO WHAD VETEAND TOERVES A A
WERCLKHIT M,HI HUT BEOU CLD
NO
HEN'OU CLD DTO TTHAIT WH HIS
DUSCHE
. LE
SOE H OERFFSHI TSREEC LTU TO
LAOS,ER T RIASPIAWNG LRSYE
HAND ENSBEGI L'SETEE SF IE  W
A
D FNINHA TTD WOR RE.
I
RLLEAY WTAN TOEA RDHI TS
BE
TUSCAES ISO RTIMPOT.AN
A>> IM NOTN A AISOMCCPLDHE
LAER.
FDINUI QTE ASUC MH MLERATIA
O
R ATU LECRE IN TSEHONT POIS
WHAV IE H FELEDS AN IHO TSE
WHAV IE HN BEEEOD MYATEREL
SU
ULESCCSF .
MY SSODGONE, HEAS W AN
SHMPCOLI EDERLAWYLR, ADYEA A
USFAMO LAER.
SWII LL TAYO PELEOP,AN C YOU
IMEIN AOD MNER ERLEAD,
ERWY, LIPO,CITIAN SSSIBUNE,
PRENIDTF O ALE COL OGER
SIIVUNERIN STYAYM IG A   NOT?
AYISTH SS SMUO CH ABOUTHO W
M RAABHANNCLIOLSHI TNKE  H. IS
O
THA HE'TOE DSNAV HE
ONBIAMTIWI H,E  ULLSE THATD WOR
A
LO BT,UT HE AOAS H AAN SE
TETIESMAF OSE HIMLFND AE  HIS
IN A SSEENNGEN BDI THE
ESSIAL LT TAWHA IRG AUE PR
OUALTH TGHHEEC LRETUS I
ACTREEDPI TASNGRI WYLAS,ER I
THKT' IS THEES FINT
-PSELFTTRORAIVEE  WHA OF
N,NCLIOL THE . WYLAER
AVWE H TEHE WDERFULCO LINLN
LERSPAL PECTRO PJEE DONOM SE
E
GOSAR A WREHE WHAE VEND FOU
FLAL OHE TSE PERAPSN I THE 102
O
ITHIS BTHS ETESHEPP ARE IONSN
OF
HOAS WCO LINLN T HE.WYLAER
>
OU Y OWKN'STH, AT RTIMPO
ANDOU YDO , YOU FINOUD T THE
MA
O ADLS HHO WME WTEAND TO
ENPRREESMS THI
F.EL
LLWE A TAN WT POSERENT
VERSOUEL ISNHE TOR W AND  I
TINTHK CT'HASLYTAERIN WETHA H
WASOING AND RTCE INLAIY,FT  I
TES WALAR, HEAS W TNKIN OF
MA  HEIS. RECAER
FTAS W AERHESAN KSAM
OGEMBROLI N.BEGA
A WITASHIERFT TS EMO.OGBRLI
YBEHA TTS T'NO B AADHI TNG IF
YONG GREOI TO BENGUT PTI
SEYOUROU LF
T.
>> S.YE
E >> WLKTAEDOR BEFEEF BRIF LY O
IRETH BTH OTHF EEP RNLIUBCA
HEY,RT TEC SISONTIAL OMF
PANDSIE AT' THA OSNEF  OE
STESNT IERNGTIHA CERPTSF O
O
BTHISK,OO N,ROHE WRE HSE'
INESWRTLH  WGITRTPAY
LIAFFI AIOATN H YNDOUEAV TWO
FRNTMES THE.ER
TH FIT,RS ITEM RDEIND ME,T JUS
I
WKEEHT MIGUE QIOSTNUS J
T
HWHICF US ISHE TPP OITOSE
SELNIN LCOUE QDIOSTNET JUS
PICWHHTYARAS WHE T RLEA
IOSECTLNA RTPAY.
>>YES.
>> ANDO S HESPE SAK OTHF EEA R
POTH ORF  SETHOUYI STANG
NTSILEETND A LNG T NTHOR
OREVI F THEM .
OU Y ,VOTE WEET GHE T
ME
,URASESOU G THE N.ME
TH
SE ERWA GATRE FYIDLUITN I
ESTHEAR PESTIN IHE T 0''4S AND
THE 0S'5 .
SO SIG MHTAY WE'DLU FXE
AG
N.AI
YEANT SOD TAYIGEOM MHTAU FLT
I
FOLNCNOR NOT BNGEIN A
ABOLIONIEI,ST B TNGOO
TEDEMORAHEN O TRYLA SVE  SUISE.
ASAL USU O TNSHIHE T FR,MEAGNT
FITHE TRS ONE, LCOINLN CTOUSM
HEE,AS TY, B TNGEIHE
ABSTIOITNI ASRE TERIGH
S,
WBUTATLDOU RRHEE BHT RIG TNHA
WIN.
H
HE
--
SEPLEA CMEOMNT ON N'NCLIOLS
TOUTHGHTHN O .IS
>>DE HHAON CXTTE OTHN ISIS H
ME
ORNT,HA WT HE CALDE IAL WAS
E
AYY NRCL,EN HRY CYLAAN R FOR
H
SI PERE TNCDEYEEHRIM TES AND
NEIN O RELA CYLD WOU WAV HEON
TH PNCSIREDEYF H CEAVLDOU HE
A
URPTEDEW N YORKBU, TE HAS W
EDDENI VHA TTTOICRYN NEWOR YK
USBECA L TEHE ERIBTYRTPAY,HI TS
D WOULVEHAEE BN THE
IOOLABITSTNI PAY,RTEI RECDVE
MO
N TREHA ,01500 VOS.TE
AN
OD SIN LLNCO NEREV FORT
LEATTH E AIOCTNNDE H CLEALD
THPL PEEO TEHE RIS,TEGHOU
ATY THE W RLDOUHEATR BEHT RIGTH
TH WO TINND A SOE HERE SEE
OLLINC TN,HEY VERICRA PCT
PO. CITIAN
TAV HEN.WI   WE
MEI ,ANE' HSOT NSLW AAYOI GNG
FTO TLOOLWNER PSO WHOE H
CO ATELELYEEGRSIT WHLL A HE T
OFHEIR IDS.EA
ID D AEEGRIT WH THEDE I OF
CL.
ETBU HANTS THE RCAUBEPLIN
PART WEIG MHT USE AER TM T
BE AIG BT TEN Y.PART
AS WD HAROR FIM H AT FSTIR
E CABEUSSHI DNA WAS LTLOYA
.
ASHE WAL LOY . WHIG
DN'TMM ILYIAEDTEOI JNHE T
BLREPUPAANIC UTY,RT B HHE WNE
HEDID  WTEANDO  TBEN OPEO T
YOEVER. NE
TH A WASTHNOERRSON CVE IOATN
HEASRI WOR AEDUTBOHE T
S,VITISTUT B TIANRYLA-SVE A
TRSPECE,UM HTID DN' TAN WTO
HE WASEDOR WRI ABO AU
IOOLABITSTNISAU BEC SSEESETOMIM
HEEL FTHE TY WEEREOIG RHTUS
E>> WINER HE LIILISNO,L I'L B
NO
O GWONOONT AERHA C ERPT
THOU Y  VEHA.
WEINER HE  ISINLLOIAY ST' IS
TH OAN LDF N,NCLIOLT' I OSN
OURICEN SEPL
E.AT
IN IIANDNAEB RSSUT UND A SA,YS
LL, -T' IS-E' WRE THE ESON,
E
AD HIM H AS A YNGOUAN MND A
OF SECOUR, ASHE TTSES JUI SAY
UGIVES THE CHE D,IL WHEVEHA T
D
T.UL
OF URCO,SECKEN KTU WYAS ONIS H
NDMI AT.LO
HE URE GWPN I AN AAREF O
ILAISNO,  L OOTF KIATUENCKNS
M
EDGRMIATO T ISINLLOI AND A
SRDBOERUSTETA JT  LEIK
KYNTKEUCND A IINAV HE HE
,SHOP INN A EN,LOVEPEIN SAYG
KE
RUCNTKYHTIG ERTHE, IIDNSE
ETH EEELNVOPT' THA NSOWON GE
SWA AIS WP OF TSITAGAN PHAERPS
FROMHE TTA S OTEFEN K CKTUY
REDENMMDE TO N.NCLIOL
WRO WTHA WASENS IIDHE TREE
ANDRO WTE IST' ,GONE I'TAV HEN
LO T AEDTHEER PAP TSO SEEF
I D FNIN  IT.
U'YOLLAV HE ANSE UNUD SECPEH
HTHATE --T WHA HE MAD-  -,NO
E
AS WN OHE TURNA IUGAL TINRA
AN HEAS W AIG RHTOSCRS THE
RIM FRRO KYTUENCK WN HE
HAULCOD E MVEADHI TS CHSPEE,
THBONGKI AUT THE SVELAHT RIG
ACHESSRO T FIV RERMRO   HIM.
DAN ASOU Y SYTAH WITS THI
ARICRTUL AGFR TNTME,THA
PA
PTEXCEOR F HANTOISRIDAR HOL
HO,ERE WH BOTNO KW WE,LL THI
SWA LGEARLYIG   RENOD.
HIOS MTMP ITANTIC POL AYS
T-IDESEN AECELTND BONEYDOT N PR
ALLOWLA SRYVEO INT THE
ORRRTEIT
S.IE
USHE JS- TWA-
S, ATWA  IK,THIN ONE OTHF E
OR ISTMPNTTANG THI HEVE ER
O
DID,O TAK MEE SURT THA H DEID
NOARYRO FMHA TTNEAR HDE D
TIPOSI OONF S.HI
HIFE D,HAHI NOTE ENGLS
AY
HAVEFOLL EDOW.
PLE GSEIV US ANTOM CMEN O
TH
ONDEULRF SPCHEE.
,WE LL TS HIISNE OT' THA S
BE IG  RENOD.
WH D HERO WTE ? IT
IDHE DTN'RI WTE IT ONHE T
AIN.
RO WTTE I IN FIRISPNGDEL
BEUSEE WD FIN IT ADACTTHE TO
A FSTIRRA DFT OFIS H FSTIR
INLGUAURA SECPEH ANDOU YAN C
TE TRO FM HECHSPEEND AE W
FKNOWTHMRO OER FAORCTS,T THA
ADHE HHI TSRE GAT AYINFFIT FOR
NTUC
. KY
APPERHWA HSE SVE OYRL
OPTISTICN I THE BNGINEGNIF O
61BOUT UONNIN I NTKE
K
BUTST  IWA CLYTAERIN D.VIDIDE
O
KE HPSEE TKIALNGBO AUT "MY
OWFELL UCKENT,ANKIS"ND AHE T
KINTKEUCADSAN H CSSED THE
IVIOOH R SERO HE HAD A GATRE
PEHOOWOM SEH HE CLDOUIV GEHI TS
CHSPEE .
HEDIEREV   D.
IGI IMANESE HK TOOHE T TINRA
N
T TDHEINRA AIVRREDOM CG IN
INTOIN CINNCIAT HE HOU WLDEAV
AOKLOEDOSSHE TO OHI RERIV
SWATORDCKEN KTUOY S T I
NKH
IT'S FTICIASNA TNGAY S WTHA
WO
DUL HEAY S TOIS H FLOELW
UCKENT AANKIS A INDN E,SENS ON
NEETH O HA,NDE'S WTIANNG TO
E
M TTHENO KWHA TT HEAS H A
GR TYFIAFNI,EC AFFONTIOR F
EMTH.
ONER OHETHHA ,NDETS WAN
TH
TEMONO KWHA TT HISE OT N
GOTETOG  SPAC BKRO FMHE T
ESLIPOCIND T IDEASHA TT
HENCNN AOUEDLL A THRGHOU HIS
ALIFEIN DNDUR P HGISLIUBC
NDS,RD A IFY THE D'TONGR AEE
WHOLNT PEOI OF ONECELTIS,HA TT
CAYOU CT ENLENEOM SEOR O DEAEFT
O
IONMEEHEN TEX NT
ELNTONTIME IBU, T THI TNK
HA S,BEENS A YOU SAY,RT APA
FR
OL HARD HOERLZ, IST'N BEE
TEMPCOLE OVLOOKEDND A I
IWANTBE TTO HT RIG IER HEN
THISOKBO.
>>,YEAHT' ISTAMP IORNT ANDN A
STTEINREG RD NLRTCEAI
Y.>>
.YEAH
ITSTYTIENRERDEA IT B IOREFEN
.>>
.YE AH
>>N APT CHAER YOUL CALNI UTY
LIT'N,OL I AS STIECON ON THE
COONTUTITI, YOU AAL TKUT A
E
ROERTT FMNDLE AXAERNSTE SVE
WHEEC BAMHE TFE CON RADETE
RECEVI-P. DESINT
Y,IAITLLOUS A Y NTMEN,IO HE
GASWA AHESTIN T N.SSSEIO
DI
'T TNK IUL STHOD HA
IBUTN ATL LIT TEOCO LINE H
SAE WN LEAOW TDAR A
SUSIONOVEMT.EN
MI' WNGDEONRI IF OLLINCSN'
OISADIPPMENTNT IN S WVETENSAS
ASREONHY WE H DN'IDTNS AR
THAT LE ERTT?
YWHO  DINU YOTH THAE HAS WO S
OLESINTN ? THAT
ME,ANE H WER CINTALYOT N
SI
ONNTLE ,S A ITI MEN EDON
REBEFO, ANDVEE  WHAHE TSS IUE
OFVE SLARY NOTNG GOINT IO THE
TE
IEITRROR T ASNDSSTHA IUE
TDIVINGHECE NASNTUB REPCALIN
PART A HNDED SAI D'TON- - IN
HEANOTRET LRRO FMHI OO T,DON'
NT'LESOTTA SKI TAL ANGUTBO
I
VEAK O NTCOCTRAS,S A A
LA
ER.
WHYYO DO KTHU INE HAS WEN SIL
TO AXANDNSTE SVEN OUC SH AN
ANPOIMRTUE ITSSEC ESP FLLIAYM
SOROEON F  TMHEUTSOH.
ET L'SBEEM REMT TRHA HE A ND
STEN S TVEERDRETOGHE INHE T
C30THSGRONESND AOT B WHEER
AIGWHS O ONDNETHF E
TIICFFUL FESOR HIM OEAVING
ETHHI WG PTYAR W HASADT I BNEE
IVERYEDREMPSSIT WH EVSTS,EN A
VERYTFOUTHGH,ULEL INTL CTLEUA
PE
. ON
RTHEY KLLEAYDIN OF . NDBOED
SOHE WN HERD HEAHA TT SVETENS
A
DIV GENN ASSDD ARESTGA AIN
THIN KD OFVA PREINILG
IMSENTNTEN I ORGE WA,GICHAS
FOSICCSUESE,ON H WAS
STTEINRE IEDNHI TS AND HE WTERO
VE STOTENS ,SAIDY M SSODGONE,
D LOEIK TVEEC REIHA TT
ESDRS, I'MER INTTEESD TONO KW
HSOME EEAVNVEGE SUGHAEDST TT
E
HAPRHSE WASAN W TNGTIO MBE
OMNDFI SE MEERODATTH SOUNEERR
HTHATLD CEOUUT PNT IOIS
CA
NEBIT.
SONSTE SVEEN ST HIMHE T
AD
ESDRS.
HEEA RDT IND A WTERO ,BACK BUT
TI WINRINGK BACE HOE D SSAYO T
BENEVS,HA WUTE VEIF DREFENT
SIDEABO AUTLA SRYVE AND SO
STS WTES TO HIM AND
YOED AVESKHE T ONESQUTI, DAN,
H
HDIY DE NOT   PLREY?
INI THS TKHI H MAYENE AVBEHE T
NNBEGIFGIN OIS HEA RZILING TTHA
TAS WN'US JT THE REFI ANBRDS
OF
HE STH W WHOEEROR F
ESSUCCBUONSI, RY TVEY V,ER
Y,DLEEO PPLIK LE EVST WS,ENHO
WHEAVLDOU HEUG THO OHTFS
TEDEMORAS, HEOU WE HLDAV
THF TGH OOPPELEF O
INALECLLTU SUE.TABSNC
ISTH HIG MHTENE AVBE A
TUNTGPINOIUSOT N JGAT ASTIN
BENEVS,UT TOZEEA RLIHA W
T T
WASAP H INIPENGNHE TOUTHND A
THNGKIBO AUT ESSUCC ONSI.
ITAVES UHE TPP OTYTUORNIER HE
ANDHA TST'HE TOI PTH ONTF E
MEAGNT AND I T MPEIPDYAT HO TFR
JOHIANTH W S WTEHOEDGEUGSTS I
T MIGHBE INY M ,BOOKND AHAT
THLA DEC ATIRAONNDHE
USCONFN.IO
ANDPR ARIMY, ANDAY S TTHA THE
CLARION TS IHERI PRYMAHA TT
DSSTANS AOU FNATNDIO F TORHE
TUNSCOTI
ONTI.
ND>> AE HRI WBOSTE AUTHATT A
E
THNGS.
E>> H ESDO .
'SIT AON WRFDEULER VSERO FMHE T
O
OKF ORO P AER VBSUTBOLE APP
F
. GOLD
ANER HES INO AERTH   AITRT.
OLLINC ISEM REKAARBLT AIN TAKG
EMESOONE' ELSS RDWOS, TS HIIS
ENSTEVDS WS'OR ANDIG D TIESNG
THND AHE TN NGSAYIBU, T  I
TH  MKYS,IEFRNDS,EVSTENT I
ALACTUNS MLYEA, TH ISTNO . THAT
HEASIT WH AT GRET AIN TAK G
SOSEE ONELDS W'SORND A TINRYG
TO UANERNDSTTD I
EMALETTHICT, LYBUHE TN
P
AINTTGREIF DFE NTINSP,
'STHAT THE WRO RDWO--
ERDIFFNTTEN IATPRERETFNIO O .IT
>> DE HSE U THEDS WORT THAE H
IUSEDS TNHIVO ,TE HAD HESE UD
AGEMTH N?AI
S, >>YE HE D,DI AHYE ,. YEA
>>
VEE  WHA AREINN TEINSTG- -
AN
HERNTERTIESNGHA CERPT IN
ETHHE TALOGOLIC LIOLN.
DANHO TSE OFS UHO WAV HEN BEE
TOHEGIN TARIN VEY ODSF
OLLINCANNIA,SP EYIAECLLN IHE T
0'5 AS AND AOLSOU THRGHHE T
ENESPRID  OCYF'6.
ASNT POUOI OUT, ITOE D'TSN
SEE WALEN GEROW ALL TTHA
CSAMEYACAPITN O THE
LOTHEO CAGIL. SIDE
WEON D'T IWE DLLONT  ISTH.
WEO  DLKTA A BITUT ABOOW HHI TS
A
SGM FRATENND A AOLST JUS
LLNEGERAY, OLLINCEC EN,SPLLIAY
THWI - E-LLECSPIAY WHIT THE
NU
OERMBSF MENHEHA TT AD H TO
ND OFF TBEO AL C ADLEND
,IMMAEDOW H DIDHEOGHE TOLALIC
>>ER HE N,AGAIE WEE N TDOTE SP
NDCKBA AK LOO ATIS H BIRAPHY,
I' MEDTIENONNGRO GWI UPN I
TH
TH SEOUISND A H PENTS A
F RTPA O BETHTIAPST ESURCHCH
,U
T DIDT WHAANY YNGOU ALTDUS
THEND A W,NO HETEEJ REC D
HITSAR PEN'AI FTH ANDOV MES TO
NE LESAM, ANDN THEVEE  WHA
FROM ADE WONULOO BK N'ER"HMAS
INANTS AND WHE TNTERO A
PEPARTT AKIACNGHR CITTIISAN Y
AN
D ANGACTTKIHE TIB BLEND A
SETNWIES T SSAYOOYHE T IKT OUT
OF HIS HDSANND A TTEWHR INT IO
THE REFI .
ENIF LE TBLUMES ,IN AS IT
DOLLOR F AF O ,US THEEA DTH
OF DIEDE, IN 18,60ND AHE TN
M,LLWIIAIVND A C ILR,WAE  H
GNNCAOTOACKO T HIS S.REPANT
T'>> ISOO TTI EMOALON AND
LESIMP .
I ARGE H GESDURAATO T T
N CHUR IGTSHWAIN
. ON CH
A THOUTFUL,H MUCOR ME
RAPPALON AACROH TO
STCHRI,NIIATYO, SE HER WED FIN
INSHI MEONTADITI,HE T'SRE
ENBEREIF DFENTGAT DINF IT
WH
EERE' HSINHI TNK FGOR
HIHEF,EL TIL WLF OOD G
AIPREVND,LS AAT GRESTON CTE
S
EACHAR PLATY CSIM TO ICT AN
ACRDANCE WHEHIT TIL WLF OOD G
U D ANYO ESEUNEDRLDEIN,AY MBE
ANDUS M,T BE AND GOD C B'TANE
OTRFO B THISTH AT E SE
TI .
THEIC LOG N.NCLIOL
ANDN IHE TIV CILAR W IS
POHALEIB T TD'GOSSEUR PPOS I
O
GTHMEINREIF DFENTRO FMHE T
E RPPUOSOFHE EITRAR P ATYND
T,YE HESE USHE T
NTRUSTMESITALIENGOR WKI US JT
ASOYHE DR OHE TT BES
TAADAPOONTI T EECFFTIS
PU
E.OS
OLLINC WNASIE BESDGE BY
NISTNDSER AICOL PITNSIA
HINLLG GIMOD ISN OUR OIDE TE
EDAN HNE KWHA TTEF JRSFEON
SDAVIAS WEI BNGIE BESYDGE B
POSCITIANND A MISTE
NGSAYISOD G IN OUR O . SIDE
IOV LEHI TS PHPHOGOTRA A,
THTFGHUL NCLIN.OL
LISNOL I WKIORNGHI TSUT O AND
HEHOEREV THTUGBO ANYDY WLDOU
EEEREV S T SHINTCUDOME ABU, T S
YO AINTHKTUTBO IOR F A WHE,IL
O
UIZREAL ITLL REAYS I THE
UNDAON O S TFHEONECD
GUINAULRA DRADS.ES
HOR Y DEAT ,IT AR YEA
BE
OREFO,R TWOND AALFEA YRS
,FOBERELNIN LCOSKS I AGIN THE
ONESQUTIAL ,REHE,LY W IRES GOD
HEIN TID MSTEF  OTHIV CIL WA
TISOME TSME IT'NKHI IN BSEE
MI
STNDSUERNDOO IOU A CEPLF O
DIENERT WA. YS
ONCO LINOE D'TSN . KNOW
I OWKN. TOBE SRR AANOGT TOAY S
BUOEE H DIE BSELVEHA TT
SERTHE'CE F AORKI WORNNG I THE
CIL R,WAFT OENHE TTO HISANRIS
HASE UHED T TMER FMALATISO T
MAHA TT DEAHE T GERENALF O
N'NCLIOLNK TSHIGINS A KITHIN.NG
DI'VERECOISVE ADOO BKRI WENTT
BYN A EALSCPIOP MRISINTEN I
AN A59 MNE OEF  OTH FSTIR
PRESSO ORSFHE TIR FST
EPCOPAL SE,NAMIRYE H SSAY
TH
WA IATT  ASAR VTYIEFIE BELF
NOTLIUNBE
. EF
SONK T IHIHA TTIN LNLNCO O HIS
YURJONEOV MEDR OVEIN AGAST
FA
TLITASMOOD G OF ANOVPREN,
A  WDHOKS WORN I Y.STHIOR
AN
DON NO  AET THEDEC SON
TIGUAURAONNEW TTHAE HAD H IN
WR
THTEITN
. IS
HE D TN'IDTLEIT ,ITOH JN Y,HA
O
TDUN IN I LISOLNCN'RRA DWE
AN
D ADU GRAEAT OFROWN
ERUNIVNDTYSI A HE G TEAVHE
TLTIE.
NNCLIOLS  INGINTHKILOUT O ,UD
SATWH I THE W OLILFOD GN I
VICIL
WAR.
OU>> Y AND I, N,RO AREOT N
REANGIN M T OYFSEHEGM FRATSEN
AND NOHAS,TE TPST' UO T THE
RE
NDERAD A YOUEC ESPLLIAYO D
IATTHN THE PEAP IXND.
NOW, YE HOUAV  AHO-ACOUT ORF
TH.BO OK
DO I>>
ND A IOP HEE' HSNGET GTI
RO AIELTST' TNDHAAH ASBR AM
LI
OLNCN.
GH[LAU
R]TE
>>AU B EC T ISENHE NDAPPE,IX
EWROTAGES 27166- A9NDOU YAY M
I
VE AIT LEON CXTTEO TAC EH
ONHAUT B TLLST' A N.NCLIOL
AND YOU ASKS UO TEA ROU TDHRGH
THEMND AUR O BLVSEESE
CTTEINRANDEIV A TRY TO
RSUNDENDTAND AUE QION AND
EPCONCEALTUIZHA WTE' WRE
INREADOFG  N.NCLIOL
SERTHE' 111 OFHE T MERTH  E.
OUDAN YNL OY GO TOUHRGH 11, 12,
I13N THEAI MN PT OTHE
HE,OK TT RES ISP U TO ,USO T
ETH ERREAD .
SO ASKS U TO BEACNT IERNDVETI A
YZANAL  E.
O'SIT S V  IEARD.
ETH IMSTE E.THER
HNOWEOE GSR OVE ERSLAVHEY, T
NA
FRETU OR,LA BO AUM NRBEF O
TISE HKS TALUT ABO   BOLAR.
WA AGM FRATENOR F THEOU HSE
DEDIVICHSPD EE CND ALYTAERIN
THE LGEONST SPONVESI' ERVE
SEEN FNYOR ARAUT AOGPH RUEST
ANHE TRE IT . IS
ROLE ERT. EEAY M BIT WHIS H
FA
TWERELLIS H TOPROS AND
RAGENEER OLRDBE NUM NENI,
RILSIT BU, T T AS HIISN
GRAUTOQUH APRENDTES AT' IS
USBUFALO .
ANF O CRSOUEY M FORITE
MEFRAGRE TNTHEHOS I SRT   ONE.
YWHENOUAN C'TD FINT I ANHEYWRE
L
OO,SE LKNT IO TH.IS
[L
R]GHAUTE
NEO S OEF  OTHENRA FGMTS IS A
TNOTEO ZHAACRY YLTA I,ORF
HADRYAC ZHALO TAYR IN FFNTRO O
M THEIM TE ITHN E '5 T,0SHE
I
SWHIGE WERIN TRYG TO GET IONT
PO ARND WTHAHA HE D TOAY S
ABCYPOT LIINND A LSLNCO I
TYISANG OTA ORYL.
NOW, IE'V AEDSKER OTHSOR BEFE
WH
TATHE PLATIARCURBL PRO SEM
ARTH OF  SEDIOLER BGOMECIN A
POCITIAN VERS AIT POLIAICN
BENGMI A MMCOINDEANR-. HI-CEF
OWSO HINID D LLNCO I TNSHI
MEFRAGE NNTOT SAKPEO T TA
WHAT WAS HAYE SGIN TO HIMND A
HO
AW SDIOLERUL SHOD LKT A
NOHI TSIT POLALIC OF
CEFI?
WE>> ,LL IOS ALMTLU INCDDES THI
N
ES A A SCCIPEFI CPTHAER
AUSCAE YSOUGGSUT'T,ES IS  BE
FAG.ATININ
ZAYARAY T WRLOAS FIN LLNCO
IC LAOG ALLESE BIOCTN,UTOT N A
SIRSPEUA VEE.
HE WAS A SLAROL HDE ANDO  N
NEEON KCT EWXALYHA WTE H
TH
GHOUT.
LIOUNOL WE HLDAVRRRE PFE TEDO
HAAD H H CRYENYLA AINGAR O
LONMEEEIK , THATETBU HAI SD  SO
E'IF WNG GREOIINO T WS THI
TIELECOU,ON Y OWKN,'V IE GOT TO
D
TMIS THI G I ASIT MILYAR
HE
,RO SO, AYOK
EE TTHRIM TES IN TSHI
MEFRAG,NTCO LINLN WAY SSEER I
ENESPRID WER I ENESPRID T,
REWE I PRT,IDESEN AND IUS JT
M
GINAGINT THAS HE'OT N EN VE
SSNECEILARYLYOT TALINPE SAK TGO
CHARY , YLTAORTBUE' HS TA
SAF,NG IER I WE ENESPRID  T.
IWERE PRT,IDESENF I Y'WAS
PUT GIN IINHA ZACRY YLOR
H,MOUTNUT B IIS H MTHOU AND
TH'SK INIT ANAAS FCINGTI
FRNTME.
ERNO ATHNE O WAS WRIENTTN I
OC
BETOR OF 5818T  AETH END,E H
SA F AEWDS WOR OF LFMYSE .
NOW,ATS  ITHN ANO AORLYMA F
LIN,OLAK SPE OGINFSE HIMLFN I
OTHEXTON CTEESES BID TSHI ONE?
>> ,WELLT I. IS
HEFT OENPO SKEN IHE THI TRD
ASONRS, E WKN ,OWHE WNE W
WRES HIS KD OF FOUAMSO AUT
RABIOG CICPHALUTTRONIBORNIO F
ETH 1860 EL,TIECON HETE WRISN I
THHI TRD PSOERNHI W WCHASOT N
UNNLUA I THE 1H NTCE
Y,
HBUTE ER WAIAGN,THA'M I
SAHE,NG T I ,RSPEONEC BSEAU
HEHOEREV THT WE' SDEE ISTH.
HEER P FCTFELYEREO TAY S TSHI
IS WHA I INTHK,HA WT I
E,LIBEEVHA WT I FE,EL AHYE.
T, >>BUIDE H DT CTAINOLY D
?THAT
>>NO,E HID D NOT GLYERENALO D
THAT NO
YE ,AH RIT,GH GHRIT, RIT.GH
ND>> AN TH OA HEOTR AINPOT,
FRNTME, IHO SDUL Y,SAER WE
S
PKIEANGNTOIS FORIS H ,TOUR
IOHION 59, ATSCFAIN
G.IN
IBUTHI TNKNE OEF  OTHOS MT
RTIMPOHITAN TSO  TVEHA
ENHAPPM FEDROT THA URTO,
IDESISCIRONTDUNGSE HIMLF E
TH IE,ST THATUL RES IDTEN
THCAUB PLIFONTI O THE
N-NCLIOLSUGDOLAESEB DATN I
.
>>S.YE
AND TT'HASNE OTH OF E
MA
SSTINAYF O A HOWND WHY
LINOLAM BECE IDPREST.EN
50IE C00OPE WSER SOL AND
RIDIST ATEBUD NDRE. AD
AN IDHO SULAY S THEROO CPE
NUNIOHO PHGRTOAPN I TTHAHPE SEC
MA HIM PRT,IDESENO S DID THE
DE OTEBASS TFHI ,TOURND A THE
NGEASPKIOINT ARENAAS FCI
I
TO. ME
>>,YEAHND ANE OEF OTHPOTSIN,
SJUSTGPPTEIN AAC BK T,BI
I
OSOME MTHF E ITOSNTORMPTA
FR
SMEAGNTER WE WTTEN D
I
STHEEBENEV DESAT WHITOU DASGL
N
5818,HA TT HEERCO LIN ILNS
G ADREINARETH VUSIOKS BOO AND
WYISANG THAE VE GETEA RDYOR F
THEX NTDE TEBA, DO ISTH,O D
THBU, TLNIN LCO IS
INCONTUSUOLYTH. KIINNG
NNCLIOLNE KW -- LCOINLN'SHE TRE
ARFON WDEULENRA FGMTN O D ADRE
TSCOTND TT'SHE WRE THE
ISICION S, MADETBU IUE ARGDE
ERIN H TETHAOM SIMETES LCOINLN
O
OLDUL HISD H FIRE .
ON AECSUBJ  T.ILYIAEDTE SAKPE
HHEAD TO TEAK THEE TIM TOAL WK
ROACSSHE T S FEETRTMRO HISAW L
OF T,CEO THELDTE STA
TOCAPILHE WRE THERYIB LRA S,WA
H
EEER H WASTI GETNG HSEIMLF
PRNDEDAR AHATN IUR OAY D
WH
VEEER EBORYDY JT SAKPES
DIIMME ELATY,N,NCLIOLHE T
GRPESTTE SNERAK ICAME ARIN
Y,STHIOROU WLDFTENOT N SAKPE
HTIUNLT FEELUL FLY ARPREP, ED
ATBU IORG AUEN WHEE HRG ASUE
INHE TES NOTOR F THE LAW
URLECTT TEHAEEE W NDO T LRNEA
SW HOTOAK TEEXEOORMPAN LYUS,
TH'TOE DSN SEA MNAKPEFF O T
OTOPR YFOU ADHE .
I,TEA M BNSUL FLY EPPREDAR,
U
N TTHET A A NTMOME'S NICOTE
IN AAR PRCUTILA ATSITU N,IO
USCAEREOU Y AULLY ARPREP,EDBE
O
TARU EBLNHE A TEOAK SPE
CONDLYNT A RSPELYSIUAVE
ND AOU YRI WTE ABOHIUT TS IN
YOURUEILEPOG .
I'EE BN TO T EENXTTIK LE
NNCLIOL NRI WTE TESOTOYS M FEL
AN
DUT PM THE AYWA AND SESETOMIM
SERVE UIN ADGAR OIMOM SETES
S
'M IINHI TNKGGHHR TOU 'L IL
THK BKAC A Y,SA GEE, W IAS
WRONONHI TSR OOR CCTRE ON
TH .
DAN YOULS A DOO THATOU Y SAY
R YINOU EP. OGILUE
YDOU OWKN,S AOU SA,ID IT
STAKEEMCO NTN,ATPLIO WS AET JUS
IDSA, ANDIM TEUTIT WHO
UPTEINRR ONTI.
US JTEF BRILY CMENTN OOU YR
TIFLREECNSON IHE T UEILEPOG,
SO
GTHMEINE W HENAV'TPSER PHA
RECOVET. DYE
>>LLWE, I DEDECID, ANDER HE
N,AGAI I TIP H MYAT TOY M
WITEDORHO IDSA, INOW TTHA
ERWRIT ASNDRSUT AHOND A
CIESPELYALMICA ADEONCS DAN'T W
T
ETO BRS PE ALON.
I I THEPI EGULOEHE WN
I
AWAS PD.NTTU SDET A
NCEINTOUN TYERIVSI, A SDENT
DKEHE TST QUE SNIODAICE ON,
WE
AT, LLWHF I ADE STU AS
AB IWHT ATHI TNKR O ELFE,ND A
E PORFEROSS IDSA,ON D'T
SWANER.IT
[L
R]GHAUTE
'T D ONGA AIN
. IT
BUT SHE,AI KINTL McKNAEN IDSA,
H
AEAR LITE OFR YOUWN O
PONRSALNTOI OF V
W.IE
AN P TDHETAR OFTH ,AT I L TEOVO
TEASPK SHIO GH SOOCHLDENT
AN
AN ID WTO T CCAMUOMNI TTEO
ND,EM AER'M I VYON CRNCEED
H
WAND ARIOREDUTBO THECR SNSEE
URIN O LET THA ARE DININOMATG
OUS.LI VE
WEE'VEDEA LRNHR THIGHOU T S
ICNDPAEMHA TT LSOTF ONG YOU
PEE HLEAVPE SNTVE ENOR ME
TIME ONHE TIREE SCRNS BAUECSE
H
E HEYAVEE BNUDRE PCLEDM FRO
ETATHL AS ICOR KLLDSIN OFTH OER
GSTHIN .
D TT LI WOLNCN,HOE W KWNO
FRHE T GURTYETSBGDDREND A
THEDEC SON INL,GUAURAAS W
TOINLLG DEEC SLULFIM HSEN I I
ETH HHI WTESEOU TOTA SYO TIS H
ARCRSEET DS,IE IAN'TON W ATNY
IN
TIRRTEUPS.ON
TAKE TESIMND AMPON CTE
N
RITO WS TTEHI WA Y.
TBU THEAY W I BINEGHE TOO BKS I
TEL TLHERY STO IN 1863 O
F O
THEUD A WNCIEELIL KNOW WHO THE
O
ADERPPHEE. SAR
IS I ASNTAR VIA OF THE
ICPUREBL DEMRATITY PCARHO W
EDWANT TONET RURHE TIO NATNS A
S,WA AND CMELENTAN V
CKATTANCG INLINOL A TNDYHEEL FT
ATCO LIN WLNASER VY ICCRIT,AL
O ICCRIT. AL
SOIN LLNCO RDEIECVETH IN EAI M
NYALBASO REHIESLV WCHER WE
GCKTAINIM HND AE H DID,HA WT
E
FT OENID DAS WPO RESOND T
MOVE  NTMES.O PSTTE
ATTHATOM MEN A SSNGCORENMA
OWOMFR IREENA TED THEEFF OIC
AN
D SDAIHA TTIN LLNROTE HIS
ONRESP
. SE
HE S TDAIS HIISAR REMBLKAEOU Y
A
NET G DOWN ANDTE WRI THE
RE
SEON.
>> HEEDOI PNTO T ARA DRWE IN
DESHI ,SK ,NOS IT' AUTBORE THE
AFOR ON LG. TIME
AMI'UIRGNGHA TT LCOINLN HAD
TEE THNOE,THS ERUT BSE THO
NON'WES REIL ATVALEABO T . US
TDANT'HAS THE TUSHRT OFHI TS
,BOOK TS HIISHE TAY W TTHA
OLNCN ATOPER,ED WRE,OT LDEA LI
LINCN.OL  EEHE TVA PRITE
TID DN'EEC BOMHE TIN LLNCO O
H
E GTYSBGRE ADDSSR O
RAAUINGUHO WLIT P TUTHESVIREOU
COEMPLWHIOATN EEER H RO WTE
TTENOS OELHIMS
ISUA ACTYLL WELDOU B ARE GAT
O YWA TD,ENUT B'MOI GNGO T
PU A CMAOMO ONT ITND AO D MY
W
NGUPI ELOEF BERILY AND'S LET
TKEEPSHIRI BEFENET BWE . US
ROUYO BHIHTUG TS UPT JUS NOW,
HAVE. BE EN  ANNDHAESIM T T
D ANWEER WENGAL TKIOR BEFEHE T
R
RAMHEOG TETBOR AUTHA WWAT S
ETHAP HESPITIM TE IN OLLINCS
I
? FE
METIME FRAN ILI SOLNCN' . LIFE
I
DUT PNOWALEMHE WN HEAS W
OVDISC INERGF.MSHIEL
DINFTGEN OWTH SISSMIISI,PP
APPERH  S.
EEBETW NE'LESRE SURERND AND HIS
E
H,ATAY MBE A A NGCON.SSREMA
U
HI IT T TNKHEAM SES A YOU, IS
H
ENE H S-WA-
YDOUAY SHI TSN IHE T OKBO,
EENWH HUTAS W O ON UICIRC  T.
I HAKIN T WAS WULDEONRFIM TE
O
RM,HI TBEO BL AEOO DT WHA
HEOV LED BE,STAK SPEUT ABO
TIPOLIPE,CS SAK AUTBOHE T W.LA
'D-- I YIK LEOUO TOM CNTME ON
HA,IS T OTNETH OF ESO REA
H
HE DID NOTO GOM HELL T TIME
N
T ADLLTHHE OERRSAW LYEEN WT
ORMEHO FHE TEE WNDKE O MRBEAY
AEVEN DAHOLIE SESETOMIM
EDSTAYHEUT O T ORE CNCUIRITLL A
AL AE INDHI TNK TTHA WAS
IM TANRTT OHI TM,OE B AEBL
TO--
THENL OYE TIMHA TTE  HDHAN
Y BSUS FELI,BE TO  E,ALONO T  HI
PLNTCOEMOE,AT T DEUNTAND
WHYO DO KTHU INUT ABO ? THAT
T DOI N' HINTHKEOTAS W NOI GNG
BHOME HAUECSE AHAE D BAD
GERRMAIA WS ITHA I
FEPROFNGRI.
>>OU WLDPL COMELETY REAG E.
HEID D NOT NOT GOE HOMEC BSEAU
E
DN'IDTAN WTBE TO  WH MA.RY
TH WAS AY VERTAMP IORNTE TIM
TOTHK,INO T-E HO ALSAS W
TIPOLI AINCKGNI GNDAING
NCHEADRE A FEOREUT FUR
CALIPOTIL , RECAERHETBU T
GHEITHUD JIAICL RCCIT,UI HI WCH
ISHECEWI TIZETH OF ETA S TE
NE COFON IICCTUTN CTRENAL
ISLIILNO A,ND HER I TIPY M HAT
O
OURUA MUTEN FRIUYD GKE FRA
H
PE HOELDE MEA LRN TBO AUT HE
8T
IC JHUDLIA T,RCCIUI TTHAHI TS
DLOALWE H TIMHE TOEIM T K.THIN
W KNO THERY STOHA TTE H
RIMEMODZE ESLIUCDE . ERTHOM
ENJOHADYE W  YTOUESSUGG TD,TEHE
TILO ANE TO TNKHI AND TO
EWRITOFOM SE HO TSE NOS.TE
,YE AHIN SCEE' WREN OAR MY >
RFO A MEMO. NT
RIU BNGP U MYAR INE HER AND
MANC LINDN,OL AAK SPEBO AUT
IMETH TT TEHA S WHEASN I AN
IN
IOITSTUT
N.>>
YE S.
P H>>ADUTER HN IHE TRE AND I
HAE SOMIN DEF IEITASDEN O
. THAT
NGSTRAYEL GHENOU I,AP HO NPE T
HA ABI E.BL
>>W.WO
B>> I WIEELVE WASHITHE
R.>>
RI>> WSTE HER MENA
.>>
YES.
>> 7518.
T' TSOHAS JTUSE MORHA TN A
CODENC TOME
.
>> T.RIGH
>>ND IHI TNKHA T TTSHI WAS
TH H IERNT THA ASUMYL.
>>,STLIENNK T IHI Y'ROUE
GHT.
>>ND IAN WTO TSK AOU Y
BR AFLIEYUTBO MYARND AOU Y R
GHOUTEC BSEAUVEE  WHATH ANOERH
USHOEID DIVEDVINT IEREWIN COMG
P
MN I ATHON AND'L ILONEN MTI
ATTH IN MEMOHA,NT TTSRI BNG
P
AR MY IN AIG   WAY.
ATTH YOU S AKEPOUTBO HOW MAYR
BRWELL A,AN WOMYE LAWR IN
IL FISNO, ORATTH, ANDHE SND A
HERBA HUSNDELPERI BNGER H
OU OF TREHE ANDO T HERRIS STE
L
HABIZET N IRISPD.FINGEL
D PPLEOEF O --E HAVN BEEOT N
PY HSOAPIT WH R FEROBTOR
PUINGNER H I ERTH  E.
ONPERS ILYAL,HI TNK --ND A I
WASKO T A WOU YTHAHIOU Y TNK
B
THTOU ,IS TT SHE --TOB RER
N
MAR EYHARL H,IS ,WIFE
'TULCODNAV HEER HOM C INE TO
TH RMEHO, IDWOT ULOT N WKOR
AN
SDHEEE NDDE MEON
AMHE T S,TIE ME I LRNEAEDAT
FTHISYMRO M ,THMOER KLFRANY,
WHEN SHEEE NOMDDE SNEEON IER H
O
HE,ME SOU F ITGH TTTHOOND A
NA
.
YE
ANDHI I TNK MYAR DIDHE T
SA
O,ME T NOTAV HEON ANYE IN
R
. HOME
DN'TO G TO BERO,RTLD COUTN'
BE E,ALONOU W HN'LDT AEAVONNYE
ERTHE.
LI>> EBEZATHN I NGSPRI WELFIDAS
NDLIL A CLDOUOT N HDLANE HER
A
THAT METI.
S E ERWANOHE WRE FORER H TO
. GO
W SSOHETENNT IO THE
INN.UTITIO
BD,UTA MYR LLADBRWE,ND A
ALHI I TNKLI E GBEZATHTIETNG
MARY TNHERO FMER ROBT TO D ITED
ASOO SASN  HE D,COUL FEW
NTMOHSLYON,SEEL REA HERO T
ELSETABH' AAR CENDET LER H
OUTGE   T.
O ATWH DINU YOTH S WHEAS IN
H
EER WHE TRE W NASO EREHEELS
FOER HO  TGO
I>>E LIKHA T -T- IE LIKT THA
EORYND AOM SEEF  OTH LTOS
OTTLEERY MFAR LINLN
DI IEROVEDNTEC REN ARYES,  I
TH
KINUB SATANSTTIEHE TAC F T
TH IWAT S EYAS INHE TT PAS TO
URPICTEOB RSTER A THEAD B GUY
IN
, TH IS DTBU IHI'TON TT TNKHA
THES N'SECRISALYHE T CEAST A
AL
A MYR WEBRADOL'SLL R IEN
MINTTGYARSEEL READS IUI QTE
RKREMA
LEAB.
YE>> AS,NDOU Y WRITEUT ABO IT
INSHI  OKBO.
AAS FNGNACITITO SRYHA TIS A
SUNRYTO I REHE.
>> GHRI
LL, RON, TOUNKHA YO  S
MU .
G'RWEENGOIO T G TOIOUE QST
S
OFROMUR AU, ENDICETBU IUST
WAAYO T SHA TT COUPNGMI ON "A
USHOE DEDIVID"T AHE TCO LIN LN
BO OPSH, THE EX NT ONES I
BUGALIRRNGHE,ME TTO SFRY O
NNCLIOL MND AYAR TO. DD
3..MTR CENAL TI,ME IOP HE
AT Y WIL FLENRID USN O
ABOCEOKWI WNDE LLLOU Y'LET G
-
GILMAS,R YETOU MAE-IL IONT
OU
EBR WOTESI SOU YIL WL KWNO
WH
OM'SAT CPGIN UO ST' THAS
AEMICHL GTRLBUINGAONME ON
AMICAN . MARY
ER LDATOT T,IMTH SHYMI WLIL
O
BAC WITH THEENMP UTEth
ITMETI W HHISOOK "THEIE SGE
OF VIG"SBCKUR T,HEAM CIGPANO T
TOPENHESSIS MSIPIIP R.RIVE
AN
D TIM STHMIS ANNC IINIVISE
I
IL CSIVAR W G.ITWRIN
D ANYIL CIV W BARFUFL WIL
ENAT YTH
5T NEH, 3 P..MEN CALTR TI. ME
I'APO S HPYO  TBEIT WH U,YO
D WE MVET USHAOM SEIOUE QSTNS
UROMFR OAS VT AU,ENDICE S?YE
>>
ER VY. GOOD
WE, YE,RE THES I AAS VT
AU CEEN,N.
STHISMSEEO  TBE ONEF OUR O
MOOP PAR RAPROG,MSO SFA  R.
NK TSOHAVEOU Y E OBORYDY
THE.
RO>>
HA TNKU,YO RONOR FRI WNGTI A
TGREABO
. OK
AVWE HE AFOT L O QNSSTUEIOND A
P
SOGOLIE ONUPFRTO T TSEF O
YO
H AUTEEOM WOTAY M NET GO T
EVSODYBY'IOUE QSTNAU BECSE
BOEAOU Y RALYLL TDKEELOU YRSF
TTHISNDEIM AOO GD HAD THE
OMUTE ANLLHI TSIM TEWITH OERSE
UYOOU WE HLDAV TEA HRDHE BLEL
GNGRIIN TVE ERYOUEIM Y OERRDED
OONESE TFHE S.BOOK
HIN,AI TASS H BNEENE O OFUR O
E
LYAL--
K THANONU,YO R-UT B YHA TNK
O
HO TSET A  MEHO.
ON OFUR OT MOSRO PECTDUIV
RAPROG IMSN--
THEOU Y'RIN BUY TGOOHE B K
EV ASON RS INGAL TKIUT ABO
IT
ISO,M AOI GNGO THA SRE AEW F
TIQUESHASON TOLT FKSE HAVIV GEN
UPND N,ROF YOUOU CLDUS JT
DO
BEOU YR  STREHE ABU, TOLS
T TOWHA AHE TRE AREFOT L O
QU SONTIS WOREE'NG GOIO T TRY
GTOETOU THRGH . THEM
NG GMOIO TTA SRTIT W AH'
TIQUESONAS HOM SEOGHE TOL IYN
ITND A MYGIPO ALO TESO THE
CU
WOMSTERTE WHOROIS THBU, T
I'
VE DE A LTLITE BITF O
ED
FINITGOR ITBREV  Y.
SOHI TISS  A BIT OF A
PA, RAPHSEBU N,RO PNTSIREDE
LIDN OLHAT LOS TFWO O HIS
S SURONS AEF  OTHDL MIDE OF  FO
6218.
NNCLIOLNEW AS WDI SENNG
NDOUTHSA M OSF TENOIR THE
DE
HSAT.
WELL HRDF HIS SEREVE
SBOUTF O HOLAMENC,LY
ONESPRSIYO I,F ,WIU LL HI WCH
ISUS JFITIED BEDAS ONNAER PSOL
YAGTRED ANDAV HGIN THETEI WGH
THEIO NATNN O HIS SHS.LDOUER
SO,ER HE I TSHE P FTARMRO
PTSCRI
E.UR
JWHENUSES FEDACIS H OR HALDE,E
DASKEIS H FHERHR TEEIM TES IF
A
S TYHI CUP . PASS
IS H S,NOTEID DLNIN LCO ERVE
SE TO WDEONRF IHI TSUP C
PGHMITSAS F HMROIM?
HA>> T VST' AYER PDFOROUN
OB
IORVSEAT  ANNDTIQUES. ON
I
INKINCOLNS IMUER VY CH
HTWEIGED WNDO A, YOU
SU TTEESD,ES HEQUONTI, NOT
LYMPY BHE TEA DTH OF HISWO T  SI
BUNSSO, T BHE TEA DTHF OHE TSE
ONRHE S T ASND ES HIISDEVINT
OMIN SF THE RBLAREMKAE
LE
TERTTSETHA HRI W TSTEO
VEWIS,O T DAS,HTUGERO T . SONS
MYTUMRGENS I TTHALNIN LCO IS
CHOR MEPT ADEHE
EOICOGALLY U
WTHAN GHAE VEIMENIV HTRE CDI
FO
R.
OMANY TFHEAPIO BGRESHIAY S
INATTH LISLNCO ,  FORPLEXAME,
INQUOT TGHELE BIBIK LENE O
QGHMITHATEUO SRESPKEEA IN THE
LEMIDDHEF O T9T 1H Y,NTCEURN  I
ECETH SDON INL,GUAURA IN THE
PR
IIOEVUSALUGNAURDD ASSREES
IBETH B WLEASDUO QTENL OY ONE
TI .
OLLINCTE QNUO TSHEIBLEOU FR
NDSME AOEE H D'TSN QTET I
I
HEAT TND EE W KDINF O FDINN I
IDEMORNALUGNAURSSDD AREESND A
EE ND GOSD' ,HELP TOO,UTE H
NEHES TMST SUBLYTIANVEN IHE T
NTGUARME F TORHEA IDEHA TT THE
ALTYGHAS HTS I OURPOSSE
CO LASINLNGE SUGNSST I THE
COSENDAUIN  RAGUL.
WHRHES HE' A TINSKGHE
TIQUEST TONHAOU Y ASK,AY TTHA
CU FAS PSMRO ,ME TT'HAS AN
IN
INRETESTE, GONE I'VEV NER
TCEFADNETHA OUI QTE REBEFO
, U
HI IT T R HNKELLEAYS I
ATOPERHEGIN T DER VYEVPEE L
E
AANDS THEED MNATITIO ONHE T
DIL  WDEILSU  ESGGT.
HEOT NVE EN SEHO W ISOI GNG
TOIN WHI TS R.WA
THEIL WL --HE TAR WOE G S. ON
WAIT A NDSECO, HSE'UP S TSEPOD
E
NGIN WNIHE T WAR, HS THE
DEMMCOANHIINR--C. EF
BUT,NO ,E' HS CEDING IN ASE SEN
TOHE T HHEIGROW PER HOWHE TAR W
I
TGH .COBEME
>>NKHA YOU,'M IOI G TO
OWFOLLNP U O ATHNOERUE QIOSTN
THATAS HO T DOIT WHIS H
THODOGOLYN I INTHNGKI,HI TS
IS
JRO FMOHIM JONNSN I
NOILLIIM,IS JAN WTSO TW KNO
WEN SEEE LIOLN'S LICOGAL
OLTHMEODMOY OGDEIOTRNSATNSY  B
IOCLEUIDNC PNRILES IROTN HE
BO
S.OK
>YE S.
>> WT HUE AVYOYN SEDESTHIZ
OMFR LINCN'OLSOT NESHA TOUT WLD
RRTFUHE SGEUGST IN HIS TGNKHIIN
THLD WOU LSDEA U T AO CSELOR
TADEUNRS OINNDGM? FHI
>>NE O F MORE INOU YR QU,TIESON
M,JIHO TE HUG HISALOG LICND A
IDEUCLNNEA I A NSSEE, H MSE'HUC
ROABRDEHA TNT THAND A TT'HAS
HEYWH TGM FRANTEN OIA NRAGA
SFALLHI WCH I CLAL THEIC LYRAL
OLLINC'SN,RA OPENGTIIT WH A
MU
ER WCHIDBO KEYDARHA TN  I
SINTHKESETOMIMVEE  WHAIV GEN
HITRE CDIOR FND AHA WTVE EN
HIAW LERAR PTNLI WILAMONER HND
I
'TDNLY FUL UANERNDST ADNDHE T
O
EMSTE DTESTONRAE OW H HNCA
COME AT ANUE ISSM FROAR VUSIO
OINPOTSFVI ,EW
OSPHILLLHIOPCA P TY,HEFNTOI O A
,WYLAERCTDE DU AELIVY, OLLF
ETHESRE AAR PT OFISEN ARSAL
TANDO ME,AR ENLSGE MY
ECAPPRTIIAONOR FHE TE WIDAN RGE
HIRFO WCA HCHE NACPP AROH THE
IS OESFIS H TI.
AY >>OK .
REBEFOETOU Y G TO THEEX NT E,ON
INTT USWAO T S FAYMROHA TT
RSFITONESQUTI I,W KNO W SHOTEN
IT AND I JTUSAN WT TOHO SUT OUT
TOAL DEEA NR BFAUFLOND A NEW
FO HA TTONESQUTI
GOHA,OD T NKYOU, .
LEDA.
O>> SOE DSRO N, I OWKN
.>>
S.YE
>>N THEET LOV MEN OTO -- I
R
EISOMEDYRYVEBOT THA RON HAS
SNOTOUNEE Y RQUS,TIESONUT BE H
KEUGGEINSTG THEEX NT
ITIESON HNISNS ARWE TOHE T U
ON THATH ATT  ES.GIVE
[L
R]GHAUTE
I TNK TT'HAS BAUECSEUC SH
GRTIQU ESS.ON
RI  T?
ICTBU MLLHEEMI SANTH WOTS T
KNIT WEGARD TO THEES NOT
ANHE TTR DESTIUCONF O SOMEF  O
ETH UCNSCOTRONTI, SHEAS ,KS
RTROBEOD TDLNIN LCOS ILL A EDEG
O
E HAV BNEDOM SEF  OSHI
S'REPANT RRCOENPOESND. CE
E DO WE LIBEEVSATTH ITR ? UE
DIE H DTRESOYNY AER OTH
PA
RSPE?
IS AREHENY RTH OERNSATELIO
I
TOER PNASOL DUMENM FTSRO THE
ATPRIVGHTHE OUT TTSHAOU Y
SCUSIN HIS BO?OK
>>NK THA U,YO MIELLE THAST'
ERA VYOO GD MMCOT.EN
DRE ADDSSHA TT INHE T
OGPROL
. UE
QUTHE TIONF O W,HOST FIRF  O
L,ALAY HND A NKIC OLAYRE A
ASD AND HOWY THEER WEN I THE
PO OSIESONFER ROBD TTOD
OLLINCT TN,HABE MAYHE T NESOT
AGD ANFR DNTMES SN'IDTMEE
ANPOIMRTANT DEN WER'TMP ITAORNT
NTCUDOME M ASNDBEAYN' DIDT
E>> WNO KW THE BNURIL PEF O DE
MA LI BOLNCN,NIURNG
RRESNDEN H ACENDER PERAPS
S
MHE TY TEDOVO THE
PR. ENIDCY
INDDI LARLNCO PTECITIPAHEN I T
U
RN LEPI?
ON T OERTH NDHAE TH, ERE,AR
E'THERDE ESVIHIENC WCH IHOW
HEIN TOO BKHE WCO LREINLN
WR AESOT NE INHE T 4018ND'S A
GSBRINTT  IOU IN 6118 .
SOER HES IN AXA ELEMP HOW
NNCLIOL TAV SEDSEHE S.NOTE
I T,GGSUESHI I TNKE H WTERO  AS
U
RENDDS ANDUN H OEDDRSF S.NOTE
I
YKEOU AND IE WOU WN'LDTAV SE
THEM L.AL
UN WEFATUL HAE VE111 I WHIS
E
AD H   311.
DID ORID DNO  I BT,UTHI TNKO  T
APPERH W WSELDOU PSUREME HE
D.DI
A>>NDY MARAV SED ON
ISHI TS TNEHE SAV GOE T >
MY BAELDWL WNHEASHE S W
REROEDAS F TMHE ,YLASUM S,YE
SHAV GEHA T NTEOTO T MA
BR
LLWE.
W>> IOTLDOU NE B A E,SLAV I
NULWOD A BOTE ERMAST
F NE O OETHT MOS IMT.RTPOAN
D MEPYAR K ITTND AAY M FBETEL
SHARSWA P OTF ATTH,T THA
E-SH-
EL>> WL, IGE SUGST ,THAT S.YE
>> W BHAE VELIL SPHER
WARONGHI F IHEM RENIN ILLSOI
BANDLILYIM SPLTS WAN TO KNOW,
O
B TESHEKOO CTAONINLL A OF
MEFRE AGRSNT O NRA FGFESOT O TH
I
OLN AT HEEEAV BN
DD,VE
EDOVSCERR O ERPRES
APPERH ISN THEPP A ODIENXTHF E
O
?OK
T>> IOE DSDENC ILU ALL OFEMTH
,
YEVERGL SINE ONEF O EMTH, AND
THWI,N,AGAITRE CDIO T THE
LI
OLNCNAPERRO PCTJEND A I
UTENEV P ATHT E BNGINEGNI OM SE
F
HELSYM SBOO SHA TTANOU Y C
ORE,SE FPLEX AMBE ME,AY'SHE TRE
WACPLEHEREHE TDI ERSTO
CAOTUL FLYIP DECRHE A
ARICRTUL ,WORD T LNGHISEIK
BUATTH,  ATLL   111.
TH N HASEREVEE BN DEONEEF BOR
ANHI I TNK TT'HASAR PTEF  OTH
DIENCTINIVSES OTHF E OKBO.
>>THO EOO BK IS A VEUAALBL
E.REFENC
>> IIST ,T IS.
ND>> AS A ID SAIO TNALY
TH OUS,ELRSVEO T BE
CTTEINRAITEIV WS THHI .BOOK
S, >>YE YE
R ALLHTIG,E' WOIRE GNG T DOO
ONOR MUEST BNIOOREFEE W
INSTJU K D ODFO A TOSHOUUTO T
V
YYBEROD AND I AATREPPCIE
YBEVERHOYOD WED ASK QNSSTUEIO
DAN DNDLIE A IAY MUM JPN
FA DOKBO,'TON --P JUMN O
BOCEOKFT AERRE WE' DEONND A A
QSWANERNSSTUEIOF IOU DN'IDT
NSTGE AORSWE TUE QIOSTNS
SEDRADESRE DHE .
DIO WTANOIV GE  ASH TOOUUT
HEND A ASK A QNSTUEIOO TAV DE
LEBRADY, WHO B IIEELVE IS OUR
U.K.DAVE
.>>
.DA VE
KTHINIG'M I RHTBO AUT ,THISND A
VEDAAS D,KEOULDOU Y AEEGR
THFNE O O N'NCLIOLSAT GRETES
WSEASTS HASIS MAAGPRUENDSMTI A
HILI ABITYO TEE S THIS AS
THYEA RLLER WEBL ENAIMED HO
DEH WITUA SITONTIS ANDEO PEPL
S
TIFF EECLYVES A HE DID,IS H
PR.TIUESM
>>YONKHA U,DA ,VEF I Y'ROUE
OM T HEK.U.,AD I HHE T
EGIVPRIL OEFAK SPEGIN ATDXF OOR
N
TDST HAWANDERL.FU
YE IOV LOUE YR DTINCON
THCO LINLN WAS A UEPRAGTIMAS
IT:
ANDDE IAS AND
ND TTTID DN'EA MNHA TTE H
DIE  H'TAVRMFI LSIDEA ,,SO  I
H
AS A LDEEARAS WIS HAG
PR
TIUEAGMA.SM
S T>>HIT WISHAHEON W T IV CIL
WA
OVI L S TEHEHERYTO WREE' HS
INARGUR OGVE SLARYVE ANDUL SHOD
HENC EMA TATIPEHESLA SVEND A HE
SA I'MTIPE ORANG ON A
ENFFDIERCK CTLOND AT PAR OF
TIAGPRUESMS IGSK AIN THE
WTIESONMET HATI IS ? IT  QU
ANCO LIN HLNAD THE UQUNIE
TITILYO M FEOVWAORRD ON TSHIB
E,ISSUHA TT ISE,SUIASP EECYLL
N
SSHE T IUEF OCIEMAN. TIPAON
L
T.RIL GH
UK ANYOMUER VY   FCHOR ATTH.
NOW,'M GNGOI TOER VYCK QUILY
SHOUUT TO JTUSOM SEF O THE
WOPPELEGCHATINGAND A ASIN A I
SA REBEFOHI, TSAS HEEC BOM
LYEASIFNE O O OUR MTOSAROP PUL
VELI MSOGPRRA .
EWE'VEN BE
E'THERSN BEE ATLET AS 40PL PEOE
TCHI FORVE ERY SONECDHA TT
WEN BEEE ON ANDOU YNO KW,
BOFACEOKNA ATILYCSEL TLSS UOR F
MEREVYENOMTHA TTNEOM SEO IS
NGTCWAHIOM, SEPL PEOEAE L AVEND
T
EORHE POMEPL CINE ,SO ,VE WE'
HADUN HEDDRSF OPL PEOE WHO HE
DJOENYE LHI TSROEIV P UAMGRP TO
OIISTH P ANTND I WTONK THA
ALUYO   L.
I
-- DO
DWEOAV HE SOMF OUR ORI FDSEN
OU TERTHETHARE AAY ALWS
E.THER
RA BSEYDL IRO FMHE T.K U.
ANO S HSHE ,REIL BL IS HEER
FRNOIL LI,ISMY JIMROM
AL
DAMABA,IDAVS I  REHE.
NKEVIRO FM AURARO, ILLIIS.
TO ANDAN BRI FMRO CHMI ANIG.
JO
M FHNRO SENNTEES O,HELL
JONK T,HAOU YER VY  CHMU.
EWE'RLAO S GHA TDO OUVE Y
JOSGIN UN  OETHE LIVND AUS JT
S
EI BNG A N.FA
A N FEWAN OFAH ABRCO LAMIN
SHOKBO
. OP
AND SO  ITHK, DAELNI, A I M
GO
GINO TS TOSHI TS ORVEYO TO
E TTOAKS UUT O ANDF IAVOU Y H E
YANLA --ST
LYTAS GHTHOU.TS
WE>> OU,LL Y KNOWS, A WEO G OUT
OF ,THIS N,RO I JUST OUTH T,GH
AS
ERE W WENIIS LTEONG TOM S OE
H
ST QEUEHANSIO TAVT HEEE BN
NGCOMI UGTHROH, THEMP ITORF O
TH IOO BKO ASLSHA TT WREE'
DE
WINALGHITE SOM WHOTOIS WH
YSTDEROOLLI NCSN'TU STAESOR F
O
MEEA RNSO OF N'NCLIOLS
INFAIL. GS
INI TH INHISOO BKA IS OO GD
ANEROHA WTCO LINLNLLCT AUAY
. IS
HWHOE IS .
ETHTHRE BADF O W HE . IS
ANT THAE IN
ITH O A
OKE THBOS IFUOW PERLNIEA RSONG
Y WHWE SULD TNOE BAK T GIN
BUWNDO, TUI B UINLDGPOR ME
SATSTUEO T HI  M.
S O T WTHAELL A SBEULHOD
INLOOK AGT AS AOR MAL PLEXEM.AR
ITENEV WH ILFAGSIN,S HE' A
BMAHUNNGND A A 1H9TTU CEN RY
HUGBEN INATT  ATH W,E A
HAVEATTHBU, TF IE WK LOOT A
THLU PSOFID SE  ,THATHI I TNK
THHEVE ORWNYSLM A OF ETH
FMAHUNSLIAINGHA TT HEHT MIG
HA
AVES WE ALL DO .
ISOT WAN TOHA TNKRY EVEEON
FROMHOSEHO WRE AE LIVUSIT WH
AN THOSEREHO W AH  WITUS ON
,SPC-ANLLND A A OOU Y WHOE HAV
SEHI TS ON YTUBEEC BESEAU W
ALUT PHI TS UPN OTU YOUBES A
ALL E ,HEOTRSANOU Y CO G IN
TH AEND SEEAN MY OF OURT PAS
IETEINRVER WSTH  E.
WERE APP YATCIEROUEI BNG W
HT
US.
MN,ROEOR TNHA NGYTANHI W,E
AREEIND A B TNGHETO HISANRI U
THOU YRE AND A WE LOOK
FODARLYAG EER T YOREX NT
SSMIIVWE AES . LL
TH
U.K ANYO
HA TNKANU,YO D AHAND TSNKO T
EVHONEYO WAS HEE BN AOFAR PT
H
EPROGM.
IT